WILL NOW COME TO ORDER GOOD
MORNING AND WELCOME TO HEARING
OF OUR COMMITTEE IN RESPONSE TO
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. LEGISLATORS
AND EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL ATHERINGS IN HERE
TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND FACE
COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL AND THERE ARE NO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY TODAY. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS. ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS. THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT PARTICIPATION
TOLL FREE. NUMBER AND ACCESS
CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEES WEBSITE. IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND ALL
ANNOUNCED IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX. EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. I'LL SAY THAT
AGAIN EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE FIVE TWO. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT ONE
EIGHT. TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN.
AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE IS EIGHT
ONE EIGHT TWO EIGHT ONE SEVEN.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECOM WHICH IS THE
WORST. PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AND WE'RE COMMITTEE
WEBSITES. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT TO BE PROMPTED
BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE AND
THEN ZERO FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION PRESSES ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THERE MAY BE A SHORT
WAIT SO PLEASE WANT TO RECEIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN
THE QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL HAVE AN YOU WILL
BE ON MUTED AND YOU'LL BE READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST
MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU CLEARLY AND WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE OF REMEMBER MUTE YOUR
PHONE FOR MUTE THE DEVICE
YOU'RE WATCHING. THE
PROCEEDINGS ON WHEN YOU GET.
OPENED UP BY THE OPERATOR.
OBVIOUSLY I MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY. IN INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. FOR HAVE THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS MUTED. TO ALSO
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LEAVE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO THE FISCAL IMPACTS
OF THE BILL. YOUR TESTIFYING ON
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY. AND RE LITIGATING.
THE MERITS OF THE BILL FROM THE
POLICY COMMITTEE AND FOCUS ON
ITS FISCAL IMPACTS. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINED HEARING PROCESS AND
AGAIN AFTER HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE. TO US THE SAME MANNER AS
IS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES IN PARTICIPANTS WERE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
OBVIOUSLY PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL
AND PATIENT. TO ALL INTEREST
INCURRED INTERESTED PARTIES CAN
PARTICIPATE. WE HAVE EIGHTY
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA ONLY
ONE ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR TO
PASS A MOTION AND THE REST ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. ALSO S.
BEFORE NINETEEN BY SENATOR
STERN S. B. SIX EIGHTY NINE BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ARE STILL
LISTED ON THE DAILY FILE WITH
BOTH MEASURES WILL BE
RESCHEDULED FOR OUR HEARING
NEXT WEEK. AND AS A FINAL
ANNOUNCEMENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE HAS NOTIFIED THE
COMMITTEE THAT THEY DO NOT HAVE
FILES OR COMMENTS FOR ANY OF
THE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. SO
THE REPRESENTATIVE WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING TODAY. BEFORE WE
HEAR PRESENTATIONS WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM SO MISTER
CHIEF CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR PORTANTINO
I'M HERE PORTANTINO HERE CENTER
BATES. CENTER BATES HERE CENTER
BRADFORD. CENTER JONES. JONES
HERE SENATOR PROMOTER HERE-
LONGER HERE CENTER LAYERED.
LAYER HERE SENATOR Y. CASKEY-
BY COUNTY HERE IN SIX MONTHS WE
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE BUSINESS AGAIN
DUE TO CONSTRAINTS REGARDING
LET THE HEARING TECHNOLOGY AND-
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. OF
INSTITUTING A TIME LIMIT ON
WITNESS TESTIMONY EACH SIDE
WILL BE PERMITTED THREE MINUTES
OF TOTAL TIME FOR THEIR PRIMARY
TESTIMONY. ALL OTHER WHICH ALL
OTHERS WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME. FILIATION A POSITION ON
THE MEASURE IF NECESSARY WE
WILL LIMIT THE ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. AS A REMINDER ALL
MINUTES ALL WITNESSES SHOULD
LIMIT THEIR TESTIMONY. THE
FISCAL IMPACTS TO THE BILL. ALL
RIGHTS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO OUR VERY FIRST BILL WHICH IS
S. B. TWO PEACE OFFICER
CERTIFICATION CIVIL RIGHTS BY
SENATOR BRADFORD- IT IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND A GOOD
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION SO
MOVE RIGHT ON TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO ANYONE
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE IS NONE. THERE IS THERE
ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
THERE IS NONE- SO WILL NOW MOVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE
INTERESTED IN SUPPORTING SB TWO
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DON'T
WANT MY INSURANCE FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD
MORNING- JERRY MEMBERS DOESN'T
MATTER NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE BLACK LEADERSHIP COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE THREE
MORE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT TO THE NEXT COMMENT. ONE
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SENATORS MY NAME IS
BROUGHT GOAL OKAY YOUNG YOUNG
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT FOURTEEN
DELEGATE AND FORMER BOILS
SCHOOL BOARD. NUMBER IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BOB GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING
WHEREVER YOU ARE- AND SANDERS.
IF THE CAP WERE MARTINEZ ON THE
RECORD FROM THE ENDING
QUALIFIED IMMUNITY PROJECT- IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO- THE FISCAL
IMPACT IS. IF YOU DON'T VIOLATE
THE LAW THERE IS NOT THAT THE
IMPACT TO THE CITY AND THE
TAXPAYERS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORTERS WE WILL NOW
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
OPPOSITION SB TWO. THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM AT THE
MICROPHONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE
WISHING TO OPPOSE SB TWO THIS
IS THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT COMING OFF
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO AND SEEING NO HANDS ON MY
COLLEAGUES GO UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO WILL GO TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. UNDER MR
BRADFORD'S NEXT BILL SB FOUR
TWENTY ONE ON VEHICLES DRIVING
UNDER THE INFLUENCE OF ALCOHOL
AND DRUGS. SENATOR BRADFORD HAS
WAVE TESTIMONY ON THIS WAY
PRESENTATION ON THIS AND WE'LL
MOVE RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IS THERE ANYONE A
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING
TO SUPPORT. SB FOUR TWENTY ONE
THERE IS NO ONE THERE'S NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR TWENTY ONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOR TWENTY
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE LINE IN KYOTO JUST BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THAT COMMENT.
WHY SHOULD SHE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SHARON
SENATORS MY NAME IS MERRY
KLOTZBACH I'M A THIRTY PLUS-
TRAUMA NURSE AT JOHN MUIR
MEDICAL CENTER AND SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA. A FORMER
MEMBER OF MADD NATIONAL BOARD
OF DIRECTORS AND CO FOUNDER OF
MAD BAY AREA IN I AM IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT HAVING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
TESTIMONY WILL NOT GO TO
OPPOSITION SIR ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE WISHING TO
OPPOSE FORTY SB FOUR TWENTY ONE
NO. SIR ANYBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY SEEING NONE. MODERATOR IF
YOU COULD QUEUE UP FOLKS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR TWENTY
ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR
TWENTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK OU. ALL
RIGHT HAVING THE OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION SENSING NO HAN
SO MY COLLEAGUES TO GO UP
WITHOUT. OPPOSITION SB FOUR
TWENTY ONE WILL GO TO SYSTEMS.
MOVING ON TO SENATOR BRADFORD'S
NEXT BILL SB SEVEN FORTY THREE
ON HOUSING DEVELOPMENT.
BROADBAND ADOPTION THIS GRANT
PROGRAM SENATOR HAS WAIVED
PRESENTATION AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO
RIGHT INTO TEST SUPPORT.
ADDITIONS AND LOOKING INTO
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN FORTY THREE. NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN FORTY THREE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FOUR THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
ONE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THAT COMMENT. I NOW
TO INCLUDE THE FIRST ONE COMES
FROM ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHE MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRING A
LOT TO WOULD CALIFORNIA CABLE
AND TELECOMMUNICATIONS
ASSOCIATION- THE SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE AND VERY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
IN IT MY NAME IS ELIZABETH AND
RAY AND I AM IN SUPPORT OF
SEVEN FORTY THREE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S MOVE ON OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN FORTY THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE SB SEVEN
FORTY THREE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN FOUR THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THE TERM. START CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITIONSB SEVEN
FORTY THREE. AND SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SEVEN FORTY THREE GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SENATOR
BRADFORD FIND A BILL TODAY SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN ON INSURANCE
TAXATION- A CREDIT TO JUMPSTART
FITS THE JUMPSTART ACT. THE
GOOD SENATOR HAS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE WILL GO
RIGHT INTO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE AT SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN. SEVEN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB SEVEN SEVEN
SEVEN IS THERE ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM WISHING TO OPPOSE IT
SEEING NO ONE AT THE
MICROPHONE. THING NO ONE ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SIR ANYONE ONLINE
MODERATOR WISHING TO OPPOSE SB
SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN SEVEN SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE OFFER
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO HANDS
OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN. LOTUS'S FENCE
MOVING ON TO CENTER KEVIN GYROS
BILL THE FIRST BILLS THE FIRST
ONE IS SB SIX. LOCAL PLANNING
AND HOUSING COMMERCIAL ZONES-
THE SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION
AND WITH THE RIGHT TO TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. FOR ANYONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX. SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE IN TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SEEING NONE-
WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE LINE ON
SUPPORT OF SB. SIX THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
HERE TO JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT LINE NUMBER. BY FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE JOURNEY CARE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE
QUITE MARC COMMENTING HERE TO
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
LINE NUMBER. TWO MORE IN Q. THE
FIRST ONES FROM LINE SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WOULD YOU CARE
MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE
HALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE.
COUNCIL BUT THE STATE COUNCIL
OF SHEET METAL WORKERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND THE NEXT COMMENT I HAVE IS
FROM LINE TWENTY THREE LINE
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
STRONG WINDS FAVOR CALDERON
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB SIX. SEE NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM WISHING TO
OPPOSE SB SIX WILL MOVE TO
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIX. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN IN THE
QUEUE AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I LEAN
BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RYAN
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS GREAT ORDER WITH
CATALYST I OPPOSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS
PATHOLOGY DOS ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AYE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOHN TERRY REPRESENTING THE-
THE NUMBER OF BOARD IN SANTA
MONICA ABSOLUTELY OPPOSED TO-
THE IMPACT OF INNOCENCE IN
FAVOR OF DEVELOPERS IN WALLER'S
SYMPATHETIC TO I WANTED TO
CREATE COMMERCE- THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY DESTRUCTIVE TO OUR
CITIES THANK YOU THIS IS THE
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
PHASE. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
THIS IS CENTRAL WALLACE FROM
THE MAGNOLIA AVENUE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION FROM THE BAY AREA
MID PENINSULA AREA IBM AT LEAST
SAYING NO TO SB SIX IT WILL
HURT SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WHO
ARE TRYING TO MAKE A GO OF IT
ESPECIALLY IN THE PANDEMIC.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COULD CAN.
CONFINE YOUR COMMENTS TO YOUR
NAME YOUR ORGANIZATION IN YOUR
POSITION I'D APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS IS CORDLESS
PLEASE FOR THE INSIDE BOARDS IN
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
SB SIX. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS DIANA HAUMAN I'M A MEMBER OF
THE THYROID IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB SIX.
THANK YOU I FIFTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
BECAUSE SANDRA CHINA AND I AM A
MEMBER OF THE EAST SIDE BOYS
AMONG BEACH CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE SB SIX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO YES NINE FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD WELL. YES
ON- AND AGAIN LOS ANGELES- YOU
WILL KILL MOM AND POP
BUSINESSES AND BECAUSE
GENTRIFICATION PLACES LIKE
CRUNCH ON LOS ANGELES DENSITY
CREATES ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING
NOT AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK
YOU. FINALLY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
HENRY I'M FROM SAVE LAFAYETTE
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA. AT CALLIE-
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB SIX.
THANK YOU I WANT TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING IT'S MERRY
JACK WITH CITIZENS CONSERVING
MANAGED AND UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M FORTY FIVE PLEASE GLAD.
RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE SB. SIX THANK YOU LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
MAINTAINING GAS AND SUNNYVALE A
POLISH. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M GOOD
MORNING JOHN MEMBERS SUCH A
MATTER THAT WAY AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS I APOLOGIZE- AND IF THE
SUPPORT- Q. ACTUALLY AND IT IN
THE IN BETWEEN HER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN BE THE COUNSELED
INVOLVED ELDERS AND TMG
PARTNERS AND HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THAT.
SENATOR ON FILLING IN. THE
BLANK ON AFFORDABILITY THANK
YOU. THANK RANGERS FOUR CALL. I
MEAN JUST A SECOND HALF OF SAYS
RUBIO SAYS RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA
CITIES FOR LOCAL CONTROL UNITED
NEIGHBORHOODS AND THE
CALIFORNIA AND FUNNY THE ONLY
SUPPORTERS FROM BUILDERS AND
WORKERS WILL PROFIT FROM THE
BILL NOT WORRIED ABOUT THE
HOMEOWNERS WHOSE NEIGHBORHOODS
ARE BEING WIPED OUT IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR STRONGLY
OPPOSED. PLEASE CONFIRM YOUR I.
NINETY. HI THIS IS A AND
GREENSPON I'M A MEMBER OF THE
NORTH MONTANA ASSOCIATION IN
SANTA MONICA MADE UP OF FOUR
THOUSAND MEMBERS. UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA COAST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT HAVING HEARD
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
AND SEEING NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVE ON SB
THREE FIVE ONE BY SENATOR
KABIRU. ON WATER INNOVATION
ACTIVE TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
OTHERS WAY PRESENTATION AND
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL
GO RIGHT TO SUPPORT IN THIS
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. NO ONE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIVE ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FIVE ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT REMOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIFTY
ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WATER IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB THREE
FIVE ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FIVE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THIS IS VALUED. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT HAVING UP THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION SB THREE
FIVE ONE ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUE
WITHOUT OBJECTIONS SB THREE
FIVE ONE WE GO TO SUSPENSE%
MOVING SB SIX SEVEN ZERO. ON
FORM PREPARES IMMIGRATION- THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION AND
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL
MOVE INTO ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY.
ROOM FORTY ACTION ME TWENTY
FORTY NO SUPPORT THEIR
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX
SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX SEVEN ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE COMPOSITION OF
SB SIX SEVEN ZERO THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
OPPOSED TO SB SIX SEVEN ZERO
THERE'S NOBODY AROUND TWENTY
FORTY MODERATES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SB
SIX SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX SEVEN ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVE AN OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
SIX SEVEN ZERO AND SEEING NINE
ENCINO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SB SIX SEVEN ZERO WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON THE S. B.
NINE BY SENATOR ATKINS ON
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT APPROVALS.
WE THE AUTHOR HAS WAY
PRESENTATION WE DO HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE COASTLINE. TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY LAUREN DE VALENCIA.
E. SANCHES FROM AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND TAMI
NEUMANN FROM THE UNITED WAY OF
LA SO LET'S BEGIN WTH OUR
WITNESSES. FROM THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND TO
COLLECTIVELY THE TWO OF YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES. SO
HOPEFULLY YOU'VE WORKED IT OUT
SO YOU DON'T TAKE EACH OTHER'S
TIME AND WE WILL GO NOW. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
WARRANTED OLYMPIA REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT PRESS THE
NINETY DAY. WHAT DO YOU RENT OR
OWN A HOME CONTINUES TO BE A
CHALLENGE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
WITH HOME PRICES THAT'LL BE
RISING DUE TO LIMITED SUPPLY.
STEMMING FROM INCREASING COSTS
AND BUILDING MATERIALS LABOR
SHORTAGES AND REGULATORY
CONSTRAINTS. UNDER CURRENT LAW
THE MAJORITY OF RESIDENTIAL
AREAS CAN ONLY BE USED FOR
SINGLE FAMILY DWELLING SO
THAT'S GOING TO HELP HIM BUT
BY. THE CONTENT HOUSING CRISIS
CALIFORNIA MY IS BETTER AT
CREATING MORE HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE BELIEVE
THE NINE OF THEM- ADDITION. I
MEAN I DOES NOT PROHIBIT THING
OKAY HOME ONLY IT'S SIMPLY
PROVIDE PROPERTY ON MUST
ALLOWED TO SMALL MULTI CAN
HOUSING OPTIONS ABOUT YOUR ARE
SINGLE FAMILY LOTS AND A LOT OF
PERSONAL NOT THAT CREATE A LOT
FROM ONE PERMITTING UP COULD
YOU HOME A LOT CLOTHING
DEVELOPMENT UNDER AT THE NINE
WOULD BE PRIVATELY FUNDED AND
WOULD NOT BE REQUIRED- BUT NOT
REQUIRE ANY DIRECT STATE
FUNDING OR INCREASE FOR
INCREASED HOUSING BUT BY.
ALLOWING MORE UNITS PROTECTING
MOTT WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
YOUR STATION TO COMPLY WITH NEW
ARENA MANDATE REDUCING THE NEED
FOR COSTLY DOWNTIME DURING THE
SIX CYCLE HOUSING ELEMENT
UPDATE PROCESS AND FINALLY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL THE BILL
DOES PROVIDE CRITICAL INVENTION
FOR THE ADOPTION OF NEW
ORDINANCE WHICH WILL HELP
REDUCE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ACTUALLY THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL AND IT
WILL HELP YOU PUT THAT FORWARD
MORE QUICKLY YEAH. WELL WE HOPE
THAT MORE FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CONTINUES TO
BE PART OF THE LEGISLATURE
DISCUSSION WE BELIEVE THAT SB
NINE WILL CREATE AN INCREASE
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES WITHOUT
MAJOR FINANCIAL IMPACT THE
GENERAL FUND WE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK SENATE PROGRAM ASKING FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE. TO
SUPPORT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME
THANK YOU. HI MISTER NEW.
MORNING SENATORS MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU FOR HAVING ME MY
NAME PUBLIC NEW AND I TO THE
OUR AND WORK AT THE UNITED WAY
OF GREATER LOS ANGELES AND I'M
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
SB NINE WE KNOW THAT LAND USE
POLICIES ESPECIALLY IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE DRIVEN RACIAL
SEGREGATION AND WEALTH
DISPARITIES FOR DECADES IN L.
A. COUNTY AN AVERAGE BLACK
FAMILY HAS ONE NINETY OF THE
WEALTH THAT THE AVERAGE WHITE
FAMILY HAS AND THAT THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE SH WE KNOW THAT
OUR HOUSING CRISIS IS DRIVING
OUR HOMELESSNESS CRISIS AND
THAT COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY BEARING.
THESE BURDENS. SB NINE WILL
HELP TO. ACCESS TO HOUSING
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED
BLACK AND BROWN FAMILIES. THAT
HAVE DRIVEN THE DISPARITIES
BETWEEN WHITE HOUSEHOLDS AND
BLACK AND BROWN HOUSE. SB NINE
STRIKES THE RIGHT BALANCE
BETWEEN RESPECTING LOCAL
CONTROL AND CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SMALL SCALE.
DEVELOPMENT THAT BENEFITS THE
BROADER COMMUNITY. SB NINE WILL
NOT SOLVE OUR HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY CRISIS ON ITS OWN
AND THAT WE MUST CONTINUE TO
PUSH FORWARD ON ALL FRONTS.
INCLUDING WHEN THE PROTECTIONS
INCLUDING PUBLIC FUNDS
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT HOUSING.
YOU'RE PROBABLY WORKING ON
THESE ISSUES WITH MANY OF THE-
UNITED WAY OF GREATER LIKE
STANDARD LEADERS WHO ARE
WILLING TO REJECT THE STATUS
QUO AND ENVISION A FUTURE WHERE
EVERYONE IN CALIFORNIA HAS THE
STATE. AND STABLE HOME BILITY
TO TRY. THANK YOU TO SENATE PRO
TEM ACTIONS BY THE COURAGE TO
INTRODUCE THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU TO ALL OF YOU. WHO ARE
WILLING. TO SUPPORT IT TODAY OR
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU. R. I.
WE'VE HEARD FROM THE PER WINNER
WILL NOW GO TO THE SUPPORT IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE AND WE HAVE
ONE PERSON AT THE MICROPHONE GO
AHEAD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS HALEY ON
BEHALF OF THE HOLLYWOOD CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE IN SUPPORT. ONLY
ALL RIGHT CONSERVE. SPEAKER
HERE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FIFTEEN IN Q. WILL GO
TOWARD FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU CAN MEMBERS OF THE
NIGHT AND THAT WILL HELP
AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT THAT INDIVIDUAL
PLANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION FOR HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIAN.
PM TWO PARTNERS THAT CAN KEEP
THE COALITION- ACCOUNTABILITY
ABOUT THE ELDERS AND HELP
PROPERTY- LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION THE BAY AREA COUNCIL
AND FACEBOOK. ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
HEARING SIXTY FIVE CALL. THANK
YOU MISTER MEMBERS BECAUSE ROSS
BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF STOCK
MONOMERIC DALE STAMBERG IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING DOESN'T HARM BEHALF OF
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING DACTYL CINGULAR'S CITY
COUNCIL MEMBER IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I DON'T WANT
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GLAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE PHILADELPHIA CREAM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME. ON THE PORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. R. S. HARMON
IN SAN BRUNO ON BEHALF OF URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS BEN ALI CROW- WITH A
BUTTON HOUSING LOS ANGELES IN
FULL SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS GONNA DRAW
FULL FROM SAN FRANCISCO ON
BEHALF OF SOUTHSIDE FORWARD HOW
YOU COMPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RIGHT ONE TO TWO- YES THE-
MISTER CHAIR BOB MAILER
OBSERVING HILLS DEAD AND
COMPANY- IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB NINE. THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KRISTA JEFFRIES I AM A
MOTHER OF THREE AND A HOMEOWNER
AND CAN'T GO TO THE SPA COUNTY
AND OUR FAMILY ISN'T STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE. THANK YOU
RIGHT TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MICHAEL COHEN RESIDENT
OF PALO ALTO NEIGHBORHOOD
COLLEGE TERRACE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE PALO ALTO
IS NOT GOING TO REFORM ITSELF
WERE A LOT MORE HOUSING
UNFORTUNATELY STIRRED ACTION IS
NECESSARY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
JONATHAN SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
NINE. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ADAM JENSEN THE HOUSING
ACTION COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE. THANK YOU I DON'T WANT
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING JERRY MEMBERS
TALKING RAIMES ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND
SB THIRTEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF ACTING LIKE. THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS KATHLEEN
CALLING FROM PALO ALTO WITH THE
FOR EVERYONE ANY IN THE ACTION
AND STRONG SUPPORT- OF SB NINE.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. LITTLE
ROCK HOLDEN TOLD I'M CALLING
FROM SANTA CRUZ ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CRUZ EMB- IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
TONY MARCIANO CALLING FROM LOS
ANGELES ON THE APPLE WEBSITE
FOR EVERYONE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB NINE THANK YOU. THANK ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS EMILY AND ALISON
CALLING FROM MOUNTAIN VIEW
CALIFORNIA AND REPRESENTING
THEM TO BE IN BEACH AND STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KIMBERLY DOWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
SB NINE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORTERS OF SB NINE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB
NINE- THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION IN THE
POLITICAL FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP THE
OPPOSITION. S. B. NINE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
TWENTY IN Q. WERE TO ONE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RANGE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MAILING STEPHENS ON BEHALF OF
SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS A
MEMBER OF THE UNITED NEIGHBORS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
I ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIS IS RAY LORBER WITH
CATALYSTS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THE SP NINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAJOR SETBACK ON BEHALF
OF THREE THOUSAND REGULAR
HOMEOWNERS RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA
CITIES FOR LOCAL CONTROL UNITED
NAY PERSONABLE CALIFORNIA
PRETENSE OF HELPING WITH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHEN WILL
HELP RULING COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR THE WORD AFFORDABLE ISN'T
EVEN IN THE BILL AND IT
DESTROYS ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I ONE
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY I WANTED TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT BUT I GET THAT TIME IS
OVER SO I'LL SEE MY TELL ME
YOUR NAME AND YOUR- THAT'S FINE.
MY NAME TOMMY ALLEN I'M CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. KEEP GOING WITH THE
OPERATION I DON'T WANT TO SHUT
IT. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
THANK YOU ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF BEVERLY HILLS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB NINE ONLY
BENEFIT GREEDY DEVELOPERS AND
IT DOES NOT CREATE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNLESS YOUR NAME BY.
FORTY FIVE. RECALL LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE SB. NINE
THANK YOU RYAN TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS STACEY
SULLINS- WEBER PRESENT NICHOLS
CANYON NEIGHBOR SAYS HE CAN AND
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE OF THE CABLE MIGHTY
MARE BURBANK REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS IN THE
EAST SAN FERNANDO VALLEY ON
BEHALF APPLICABLE CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU I'M
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
THIS IS KATHY PRICED HILLS TWO
THOUSAND FRIENDLY HILTON
ACCOUNT OF ONE THOUSAND HILLS
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE BECAUSE ONE
SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL AND WE
ARE A GREATLY GOING TO SUFFER
FROM INGRESS COSTS WERE
GYRATING NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION AT THIS POINT NAME
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
PLEASE EVERYONE CONFINE
YOURSELF TO THE- THOSE COMMENTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE FIVE
FIVE. ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ASSEMBLY CALVIN
SHERMAN OAKS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS WE OPPOSE. THANK YOU
RYAN SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE SIX THREE. FIND ONE
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS JENNIFER HOLDEN I AM WTH
APPLICABLE CALIFORNIA UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND THE MANGAN PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU IN
ORDER TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
IT'S MERRY JACK WHICH ISN'T
PRESERVING VENISON UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND I
OPPOSE SB NINE. THANK YOU I'M
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
ENGAGE IN LOS ANGELES FRANKEN
CORRIDOR COMMUNITIES WORKABLE
CALIFORNIA AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
WE VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE SB NINE.
THANK YOU VERY EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M ELIZABETH
HAMMERING SAVE LAFAYETTE
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE- EIGHTY ONE. I MEAN.
NINE MY NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BY. NINETY HI ADDITION AND
GREENSPAN AGAIN UNITED
NEIGHBORS LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND NORTH THE MONTANA
ASSOCIATION IN SANTA MONICA.
LOSING NINE IT SIMPLE LET'S
JUST START WITH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS HOLLY
OSBORNE A RESIDENT OF REDONDO
BEACH IN A REGISTERED
PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER AND
MEMBER UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M FORTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DAVID SOLOMON- NUMBER OF- YOUR
BROTHER SANTA MONICA STRONGLY
AND VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE. CHANGE
YOUR MIND SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS CORDLESS WILLIAM
A MEMBER OF THE EAST SIDE
VOIGTS IN LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
WE GET HOME AT LEAST OPPOSE SB
NINE. THANK YOU I DON'T I DON'T
FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHE BYRNE
FROM THE HIGH FIRE COUNTRY OF
MONEY EITHER WITH THE PATIENT
OPPOSED. THANK YOU BYE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS CHRISTINE ROBINSON AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF BURDEN
VALLEY NEIGHBOURHOODS. STEPPING
BENDING OVER THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS NOT TO CONVERT
BALLYMURPHY LAFAYETTE I AM ALSO
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
LAFAYETTE HOMEOWNER SCALPEL
REPRESENTING OVER FIFTY
HOMEOWNERS GROUPS AND HOAS
LAFAYETTE STAND IN UNITY WITH
UNITED NEIGHBORS IN OPPOSITION.
SB TEN. THANK YOU NINE FORTY
FOUR PER GO OUT. MEMBERS OF THE
NOT ICON IN AGAIN ACTION ON
BEHALF ADAM ACTED CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE YET TALK TROUBLE
GETTING ONLINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE THREE FOUR. I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM THE SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE AND
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE LEVINE S. B. TEN.
SENATOR WIENER. ON PLANNING AND
ZONING HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
DENSITY. THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL GO TO
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN- IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
TWELVE IN Q. FOUR TWO LINES
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE THREE FOUR. BOARD
HIGHLIGHTED FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NO WE NOT ENOUGH. THE
NOT ENOUGH THEY HAVE PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
CALIFORNIA B. AS THE SPONSOR.
MANNING AND URBAN RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION AT- ARTICLE MENTAL
BUILDERS THAT INTEL HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA GMG
PARTNERS VERY ACCOUNTABLE
FACEBOOK AND THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION ALL AND
TRUMP SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M SURE EIGHT PLEASE CALL.
GOOD MORNING JUST HIGHER BEHALF
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
TEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU I WON
TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DON'T KNOW YET CROW ABANDONED
HOUSE IN LOS ANGELES IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARANTES HARMON
IN SAN BRUNO SENATE-DISTRICT
THIRTEEN ON BEHALF OF URBAN
ENVIRONMENTALISTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL COHEN
CALDERON- MIDDLEBROOK COLLEGE
TERRORISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO SPELL IT
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T WANT TO THANK
YOU NUMBER ARE JUST NAY NAME
AND POSITION ITSELF. THANK YOU
RYAN EIGHTY SO THREE GO AHEAD.
NINE EIGHT SEVEN. THIS WAY TO
ONE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING AGAIN SURE
NUMBERS STARTING CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS AND SB THIRTEEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. THANK
YOU I DON'T WANT TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BOB MILLER
HERDS HILLS SOUTHERN COMPANIES
MENTIONED EARLIER BUT I'M I WAS
ON THE LINE SO I THE NEW SCORED
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU I ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BILL
COMING AT ME FROM LOS ANGELES
INSTRUCT THE PORT- AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU I TO ONE TWENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RIGHT. ONE TWO
ZERO. TWENTY ONE THIRTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND- GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ROBERT FROM
DELL CALLING ON BEHALF OF SANTA
CRUZ DMB IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU TWENTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
DACTYLS INDOORS CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ONE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND DAVID
MCCORD DEAD GHOSTS RIDEAU I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THEM SB TEN.
ZERO ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING HI
COUNTY BEING BEGAN WITH PLAN
BUT FOR EVERYONE AND IN THE
ACTION IN SUPPORT OF ATHLETES.
YOU'RE RIGHT ONE FORTY EIGHTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM LEON
ROBERTS WITH MOUNTAIN VIEW YEMI
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB TEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT OF SB
TEN WILL NOT GO TO NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY AROUND TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP ON
THE LINE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB TEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT TWENTY IN Q. WHAT
WERE TO ONE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I NEED BROKEN COALITION
FOR SAN FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
I DON'T WANT FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE
MEMBERS PATHOLOGY DOCTOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RISE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MODERATOR MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
THAT AT THE TOP OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I DON'T
WANT TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS JAMESTHE
RECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LAKE COUNCIL WAIVERS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
MATT KREMIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA THAT A
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS WE ARE STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN KEITH
DONE ON BEHALF OF THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL OF IRON WORKERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU BYE ONE
ALSO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BERMAN
THAT THE AGENT ABOUT. THANK YOU
I FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HE JUST- THEY HAVEN'T THREE
THOUSAND MAYBE OUR HOMEOWNERS
RESIDENTS CALIFORNIA CITIES FOR
LOCAL CONTROL UNITED NEIGHBORS
ANIMAL CALIFORNIA CALPERS WILL
FUND LOCAL CAMPAIGNS OVER TO.
THANK YOU LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MAINTAINING STAFFING
FROM SUNNYVALE UNITED NEIGHBORS
A MEMBER OF UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MIKE WEST REPRESENTING
THE INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES ALSO IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PLEASE VOICE AND LONG
BEACH CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN. THANK YOU
I DON'T WANT TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO. YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. I BELIEVE BLOODY
MARY BURBANK REPRESENTING
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA FOR THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY AND STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU VERY
TWELVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
DEBBIE PRICE WILL TWO THOUSAND
LOS ALTOS HILLS. UNITED
NEIGHBORS LITTLE CALIFORNIAN
CATALYST IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARIA PABLO
CALVIN SHERMAN OAKS HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION MEMBER OF UNITED
SAVERS WITHOUT WEARING OPPOSED
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I NINETY
THREE IS GO AHEAD. HI AND
GREENSPON FROM UNITED NEIGHBORS
GLOBAL CALIFORNIA AND A DENT
SANTA MONICA- AYE OPPOSED NO
PRICE TAG ASSOCIATED WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE IN JUST YOUR
NAME AND YOUR- WELL. HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNIFER HOLDEN I AM
WITH APPLICABLE CALIFORNIA
UNITED NEIGHBORS IN THE MANGIN
PARK NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION
IN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA NINE
IN STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
I DON'T WANT TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MERRY JACKSON'S
AND PRESERVING BALANCE AND
UNITED NEIGHBORS IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
THIS IS SANDRA WALLACE FROM THE
MAGNOLIA AVENUE RESIDENTS
ASSOCIATION AND THE TREE CANOPY
WILL BE DEVASTATED BY BOTH NINE
AND I HAVE AN IDEA OF ANY LEGAL
CONCERNS SURE SURE NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
THANK YOU I'M FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RECALL REPRESENTING
SAN FRANCISCO'S CULTURAL ACTION
NETWORK UNLIVABLE CALIFORNIA
OPPOSE S. B. TEN. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ELIZABETH HENRY FROM
CITY OF LAFAYETTE LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA LIVABLE CALIFORNIA.
AND UNITED NEIGHBORS FONG
CAMPOS TEN. THANK YOU VENTURE
EIGHT PLEASE CALL. ANY GEOGHAN
AND HOW FOR COURT COMMUNITY
LIVABLE. UNITED NEIGHBORS READ
THE IMMENSELY OPPOSED SB TEN.
THANK YOU RYAN THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS HOLLY
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT OF REDONDO
BEACH A MEMBER OF UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES DAVID SOLOMON
REPRESENTING SANTA MONICA
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSED TO- H. T.
AND STIR WIENER. THANK YOU I
DON'T WANT FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD HONOR INTERVIEW HOLD
UP PER SECOND- FOLKS IF YOU
COULD REFRAIN FROM REFERRING TO
THE AUTHOR THAT WOULD BE GREAT
JUST PLEASE YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION AND YOUR POSITION.
THANK YOU ONE FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JANET WEST
MEMBER OF THE EAST SIDE BOYZ IN
MIND BEACH CALIFORNIA I'M IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IF YOUR MEMBERS MIKE MONTY
GONNA BE KEPT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL IN THE WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU THANK
YOU RYAN SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HEY TORN BOARD HOLLYWOOD
HOMEOWNER MEMBER OF LIVERPOOL
CALIFORNIA VEHEMENTLY
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
RYAN FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BRANCH FOUR FOUR. OUR REGION
MEMBERS OF THE MATTER THAT
AGAIN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTUMN REGULARLY AT THE-
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
COMPREHENSION OF COMMERCE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY.
NINE FOUR. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE GUESTS PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SORRY MY NAME IS
CHRISTINE ROBINSON AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF BURKE
VALLEY NEIGHBORHOODS GROUP
REPRESENTING A THOUSAND
HOMEOWNERS RENTERS A BIRD
CALLING THE CITY OF LAFAYETTE
I'M ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE LAFAYETTE PARISH COUNCIL
REPRESENTING OVER FIFTY
HOMEOWNERS GROUP THAT ENJOYS
NOT YET. ARE BOTH MEMBERS OF
THE NAY. AND WE STANDING UNITY
WITH OUR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING THE
PROBLEM SOMETHING WHICH HAPPENS
TO BE IN THE HANDS OF CORN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SHIFTING TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
FIVE THREE MARSHON- MONSTER
.COM BEHALF OF WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE I STRONG SUPPORT
APOLOGIZE I WASN'T ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THERE. THANK YOU I'M
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES PLEASE MY NAME IS
STACY SELON CYNICAL CANYON
NEIGHBORS ASSOCIATION MEMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS TRONGLY
OPPOSED SB TEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BOB IT'S
NOT AND I AM A MEMBER INSIDE
FOR SOME LONG BEACH I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB TEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY ONE FIFTIES THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SHOULD BE FINE
BURKE SANTA BARBARA OPPOSE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
TENSING NO HAN SO MY COLLEAGUES
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA CONTRACTS
BY SENATOR WIENER HAS WAY
PRESENTATION. ALL RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL GO TO
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE SO MANY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVEN NINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE SEVEN NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
THREE IN Q. WATER LINE FORTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE QUALITY
CALIFORNIA COSPONSORED THE BILL
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
DON'T WANT FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. COULD YOUR MEMBERS
COUNTY MOST OF THEM HAVE TO THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
CO SPONSOR AND STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SEVEN NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI FAITH
JOHNSON- CALIFORNIA INDIVISIBLE
STAYED STRONG IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE MOMENT. I HAVE
TWO MORE IN Q. OR TRY LINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING BRITAIN CRIMES ON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS MATTHEW THIRTEEN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB THREE
SEVENTY NINE THANKS SO MUCH.
THANK YOU RYAN FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MATTER NOT
LAST PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSE
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
AND NARAL PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA- I FOUNDER OF THE
MEASURE IN PART IF YOU. THANK
YOU LINE ONE FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WARNING THIS PROBLEM.
PARTICULARLY IN BE MY PERSONAL
CAPACITY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB THREE SEVENTY
NINE. MEMORY WITNESSES- ABOUT
FORTY TWO OR TREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. OPPOSED THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB THREE SEVEN
NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITE S. B. THREE
SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT Y. NUMBER. AND WE'RE GOING
TO ONE SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE- YES I'M- ACTUALLY CALLING
IN SUPPORT OF THREE SEVENTY
NINE I WASN'T ABLE TO GET
THROUGH EARLIER. IN THE BALLOT
STORY. CAN I GO AHEAD YEP GO
AHEAD. OKAY ISABEL'S STORY I'M
REPRESENTING INDIVISIBLE STATE
STRONG WHICH IS A COALITION OF
EIGHTY GROUPS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SEVENTY NINE. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE TO TAKE IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OF THREE SEVENTY
NINE I BELIEVE. AND WE ARE
COMING BACK TO THE CAUGHT MY
COLLEAGUES SEE NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OFF WITHOUT OPPOSITION
SB THREE SEVENTY NINE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. LEVINE S. BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT. BY SENATOR
WIENER AND PLANNING AND ZONING
LAW- THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THE CENTERS WAY
PRESENTATIONS OF ALL RIGHT TO
FORTY TWO OH THREE FOR SUPPORT.
OF SB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT SEE NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT.
ON THANK YOU IF YOU WISH SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. FOR SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT FOUR IN Q. OR TWO ONE
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CAREY MEMBERS OF THE
MATTER THAT LEGAL PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIAN B. SPONSORED THE
MEASURE FIELDS GETTING CO
HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA. SPUR THE GREEN IN
IT YOU CAN DO PARTNERS IF YOU
COULD CALL US AND CANCEL
THEMSELVES ELDERS. AND BAY AREA
COUNCIL. ON STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK RIGHT ONE SO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
AN ARCHAIC CROW MONSANTO'S
CALIFORNIA CALLING IN FULL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I ONE THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING OF THE PROFITS ALTHOUGH
SILVA CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SANTA CRUZ BMB IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU RUN ONE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES JORDAN
CRIMES ON BEHALF OF THE
PENINSULA YOUNG DEMOCRATS AND
IMPROPER EVERYONE IN SB
THIRTEEN IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THAT BEFORE SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANKS THANK YOU ONE SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CALCULATOR MAY BELIEVE SANTA
CRUZ CALLING STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS KIMBERLY DONE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING OUT AND GET BACK WITH
THE HOUSING ACTION COALITION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
EMILY RAMOS COULD NOT BE IN BE
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION REST BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE
THERE'S NORMALLY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NINERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED AS BEFORE
SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
FIFTEEN IN Q. WILL GO TO ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MEAN
BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
I'M FIFTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS BECAUSE SANDRA
CANNOT AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
EAST SIDE VOICE IN LONG BEACH I
STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT. THANK YOU I WANT ALL TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MARY
JACKSON SINCE PRESERVING
PENSION UNITED NEIGHBORS IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I ONE FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JANET WEST MEMBER OF THE
EAST SIDE BOYZ IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CORELESS LEE BORIS
LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I TO ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JONES NINE ZERO GRANDMA
RESIDENTIAL. LOS ANGELES
OPPOSED. THANK YOU I WON TWENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING AND ONLY GOOD WILL
HAPPEN HERE BURBANK SPEAKING
FOR A LITTLE CALIFORNIA A SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I'M FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND ALLOW
RECALLS SAN FRANCISCO'S
CULTURAL ACTION NETWORK THEY'RE
MOVABLE CALIFORNIA UP CLOSE
THAT'S BEEN FOR SEVEN EIGHT.
THANK YOU I DON'T WANT TWELFTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS
JENNIFER HOLDEN I AM WITH A
LITTLE CALIFORNIA UNITED
NEIGHBORS IN THE MANGIN PARK
NEIGHBORHOOD ASSOCIATION IN
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MEMBER OF EASTSIDE BOYS COME ON
THE CALIFORNIA AND AYE OPPOSED
SB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. THANK YOU
I WON SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU- I'M A MEMBER
THIS IS LISA MORRIS AND I'M A
MEMBER WITHINA VALLEY
COMMUNITY ASSOCIATION AND I AM
AND THE ASSOCIATION OPPOSE.
THANK YOU LINE THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
HOLLY OSBORNE A RESIDENT OF
REDONDO BEACH MEMBER UNITED
NEIGHBORS UNLIVABLE CALIFORNIA
AND OPPOSITION TO FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT IS WRITTEN. THANK YOU I'M
AT ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ELIZABETH HENRY IN LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA FROM SAVE LAFAYETTE
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA AND UNITED
NEIGHBORS. STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU I'M SIXTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. R. K. TOWARD
BOARD HOLLYWOOD HOMEOWNER- A
MEMBER OF LOCAL MOBILE
CALIFORNIA STRONGLY OPPOSED.
THANK YOU I'M FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE GLAD. BY ANY DIGGING IN
HOLLYWOOD FRANKLIN CORRIDOR
COMMUNITIES LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
NIGHT NEIGHBORS WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AYE NINETY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING THIS IS AN
GREENSPON. MY CANNOT
ASSOCIATION IN SANTA MONICA
UNITED NEIGHBORS UNLIVABLE
CALIFORNIA AND STRONGLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU I NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS KRISTEN
RASMUSSEN AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF BURKE VALLEY
NEIGHBORHOOD STRIPPER BEGINNING
A THOUSAND HOMEOWNERS AND
RENTERS BURKE VALLEY CITY
LAFAYETTE I AM ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE LAFAYETTE
HOMEOWNERS COUNCIL REPRESENTING
OVER FIFTY I'M. A NURSE GROUP
THAT ENJOYED THE MAFIA. WE ARE
BOTH MEN OF THE UNITED
NEIGHBORS AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN ONE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THIS IS
RAY MARC BERMAN CATALYST.
OPPOSE BILL FOR SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU I'M FIFTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WE JUST AFFECT ON
BEHALF OF THREE THOUSAND
RIVIERA HOMEOWNERS RESIDENTS
AND CALIFORNIA CITIES THE LOCAL
CONTROL UNITED NEIGHBORS AND
LOCAL CALIFORNIA OPPOSED TO
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT IS WRITTEN.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING TO CENTER
SKINNER HAS THREE BILLS BEFORE
US. FIRST ONE IS S. B. TWENTY
SEVEN ON CARBON SEQUESTRATION
THE CENTERS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. SO GO RIGHT TO OUR
GENERAL SUPPORT COMMENTERS-
THERE'S NOBODY REPORTED TO A
THREE SEVEN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. FIGHTERS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE MINING
KEWL BRIAN CHESKY THREE PLEASE
GO AT. DAVID MCCORD TO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB. TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU I'M FIFTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU. I REMEMBER COMPOSITION SB
TWENTY SEVEN. THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSES ANYONE IN
TWENTY FORTY KNOW AS MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE COMMENT THANK YOU
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT MY NUMBERS. SB ONE MORE
MOMENT. ONE ONE EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE NINE
ONE. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY
SEVENTH SEEING NO HANDS MORE
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES
THAT OBJECTION SB TWENTY SEVEN
GO TO SUSPENSE WILL MOVE ON SB
THREE FIVE FOUR CENTER SKINNER
ON FOSTER YOUTH AND RELATIVE
PLACEMENT- THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES BUT WE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT FROM ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE XING NOBODY
FROM ROOM TWENTY FORTY SEEING
NOBODY. TO ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE MODERATOR WISHING TO
SUPPORT SB THREE FIVE FOUR.
THANK OU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIVE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE COMMENTING HERE TO
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT
LINE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ABOUT SB ONE MORE
MOMENT. BY ONE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT WILL BE CANCELED
ON BEHALF OF AT THE AYE YOU
CALIFORNIA AND. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB THREE FIVE
FOUR THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY JIMMY OF FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEVEN ROUTE TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB THREE
FIVE FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THREE FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE FIVE FORCING A QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS TWO THREE FIVE
FOUR GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
SB THREE SIX FOUR BY SENATOR
SKINNER ON PEOPLE MEALS FREE
SCHOOL MEALS FOR ALL ACT. THIS
IS SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WILL MOVE TO GENERAL PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE IS
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MOTOR IS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE
SIX FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
THREE SIX FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I CURRENTLY HAVE THREE COMMENTS
YOU'LL WANT TO Y NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND SENATORS PANEL
AGAINST REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB THREE SIXTY FOUR. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA AND WHAT ABOUT THE
THREE SIXTY FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO OUT. SB SAMPLES YEAH
YOU CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
CREATION THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE ON OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE SIXTY FOUR THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO A THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE KEEP UP
THE OPPOSITION. SB THREE SIX
FOUR. BECAUSE YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK AND UP. TO ASK THREE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE MINING Q. RIGHT EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HERE
MEMBERS IN YOUR HANDS WE HEAR
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION IT'S IMPORTANT SB
THREE SIX FOUR YEAH. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE
TAKE IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
TO SB THREE SIX FOUR. AND WE
HAVE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE SIX FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO
SENATOR CORTESE AS FOR MEASURES
BEFORE STARTING WITH SB THIRTY
ONE. ON BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION SISI'S A SPENCE
CANDIDATE THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES MOVE RIGHT INTO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE SEVEN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY ONE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
COMPOSITION OF SB THIRTY ONE
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION
SB. THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE FOR IN Q. OVER
TWENTY FIFTEEN. THANK YOU
MODERATOR MISTER CHAIRMAN THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN SMITH HERE
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. WE ARE POSTED.
THANK YOU I WON TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE ONE TWO
ONE. I'M TRYING TO ONE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. RICHARD
MEMBERS THE ONLY GATHERED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU I'M FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MIKE WEST REPRESENTING
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES WE STAND WITH
THE BUILDING TRADES ALSO AND
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RUN ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHICH HASN'T JAMES
THEREAFTER AGAIN OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THIRTY ONE-
WITHOUT ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION TO
BE THIRTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING SB THIRTY SEVEN
FIVE- CENTER CORTESE. HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO AND
THIS IS ON CONTAMINATED SITE
CLEANUP AND SAFETY- THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES OR SOMEBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
SUPPORT. FOR SOMEBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
MODERATE AS OR ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY SEVEN NOW IS THE TIME.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT THREE IN CUBA FORTY ONE
FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
BUT THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVE THE CALIFORNIA
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION TODAY BECAUSE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR OR
NARROWING THE SCOPE AND IMPACT
OF THE BILL. BUT AS IT'S
CURRENTLY WRITTEN WE DO HAVE
MAJOR CONCERNS THAT WILL IMPOSE
SIGNIFICANT COST INCREASES ON
THE WAY MINOR PROJECT
UNDERTAKEN BY BOTH STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS FIND THOSE OF MOVES
FORWARD. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD- EILEEN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS SPEAKING ON MY
OWN BEHALF JOINING WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I WON
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
RICHARD MARCUSSEN FOR THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT IF AMENDED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MISTER JAMES
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS AND CROSS
THE BORDER. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU I
WILL NOT GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTY SEVEN. THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE WISHING TO OPPOSE SB
THIRTY SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION SB
THIRTY SEVEN ANSWERING A
QUESTION FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THIRTY
SEVEN OF SUSPENSE MOVING SB
THREE THREE FIVE ON WORKERS
COMPENSATION LIABILITY BY
CENTER CORTESE TO SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION.
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
BUT WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE IN SUPPORT WATER
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THREE FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE THREE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
TO A POSITION OF SB THREE THREE
FIVE. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB THREE THREE FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE THREE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE COMMENTING Q. THAT COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE ONE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LORD
GAVE WILL BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION RESPECT WE'RE CLOSE.
THANK YOU I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME I MEAN TO IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION FROM SB THREE
THREE FIVE ENCINO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE THREE FIVE
AGO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME FOR
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH PILOT
PROJECT IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE WATER IS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. AND WE'LL GO RIGHT
TO THE PUBLIC COMMENT- IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NOBODY HERE FROM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE. MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY SUPPORT FOR
SB. THREE SEVEN THREE NINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT TO ASHBY IS SEVEN
THREE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE TWO COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS BATTLING TO BERKELEY UP.
AND SHALL POVERTY HELLO IN THE
PORT OF. THANK YOU I'M FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JORDAN HOEKSTRA A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH IN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION IN ORDER SB SEVEN
THIRTY RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT REMOVED
OPPOSITION SB SEVEN THIRTY
NINE- THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL OPEN UP PUBLIC
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
REPORTED TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE AND-
OPPOSED SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE ON
THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN THREE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT UNDERTAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION TO THIS BEAST SEVEN
THREE NINE ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN
THREE NINE WILL GO TO SUSPEND.
FOR NOW AND MOVED TO CENTER
GROVE HAS A NUMBER OF BILLS
BEFORE STARTING WITH SB THIRTY
NINE. ON FRAUDULENT CLAIMS. IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE
ARE NO WITNESSES IN SUPPRIMER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT TO OPEN UP
THE GENERAL. PUBLIC TESTIMONY
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. SOMEBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. FIGHTERS OR
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY
NINE ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. WE HAVE
NO MONEY IN THE QUEUE ABOUT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE TURN A PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB THIRTY
NINE IN GERMANY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. OPPOSED THE THIRTY NINE
AND- WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINE
IS OR ANY OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THIRTY NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT-
WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION SB THIRTY NINE AND
SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION A
SPEAKER AND I WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. BERMAN S. B. TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN BY SENATOR GROW
SIGN VEHICLE TRAILERS- THIS IS
SPENT CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WE'LL GO
RIGHT TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY-
THERE'S NO THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. SPEECH TO EIGHTY SEVEN.
MODERATOR P. COULD PROMPT THE
WITNESSES WHO WANT TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN NOW WOULD BE THE TIME.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION TO
THE SP TWO EIGHTY SEVEN-
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES OR
HOW MANY ROOMS FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY- MODERATOR
THINKING QUEUE UP THE
OPPOSITION SB TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
NOW WITH THE THEIR TIME. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AS B. TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE SECOND SUPPORT
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN. EMAIL QUESTION FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
TO TWO EIGHTY SEVEN WILL GO TO-
APPROACH THAT WAS ON VEHICLE
TRAILERS S. B. TWO EIGHTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR GROW. SB FIVE TWENTY
FIVE IS OUR NEXT BILL ON SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND MENTAL HEALTH
EFFECTS. THIS IS THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY REPORTED OR
THREE WHICH NOBODY HERE SEVENTY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY LETTERS OR
ANY SUPPORT. PRESS THREE FIVE
TWENTY FIVE ON THE PHONE LINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWO FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO SINK. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT UP. ON SB FIVE TWENTY
FIVE ON SCHOOL CLOSURES THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY FIGHTERS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TWO
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TWENTY
FIVE AND I SEE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE TWENTY FIVE.
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE ONLINE SB.
SIX FIFTY EIGHT. BY SENATOR
GROW. WHICH IS ON PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTIONS FOR DIFFERENT ABLED.
VETERANS THAT IS A TAX LEVY.
AND THE IS A SYSTEM CAN EMERGED
IS WHERE SO MOVE ON TO PUBLIC
TO. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. OF ANY ROOM TO
FORTY FIGHTERS ANYWAY ON THE
PHONE LINE IT'S OF S. SIX FIVE
A- THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK AND- TO ASK SIX EIGHT.
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA OPPOSITION SB SIX FIFTY
EIGHT OF SENATOR GROVE THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY REPORTED TO A THREE HAVE
A ROOM TWENTY FORTY FIVE TWENTY
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIX FIFTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX FIVE
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENTS IN Q. TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES ON SB SIX FIFTY
EIGHT. SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SIX FIFTY EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE SENATE OR WHITE COUNTY
HAS TWO BILLS THE FIRST OF
WHICH IS A SUSPENSE KENNEDY
NEEDS WAY PRESENTATION- WE HAVE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF HIS P. FORTY TWO ONE
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL. BOARD OF ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY- THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL GO RIGHT TO
TESTIMONY SUPPORTERS NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. YOU CAN
DO FOR IF YOU WANT OTHER
SOMEBODY FROM IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY TWO THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY. AND
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FORTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT WHEN I GO TO
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES RECOVERY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FORTY BATTERIES
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO S. B. FOR. THE TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FORTY TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENTS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
HAVEN'T TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB FORTY TWO AND
SEE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FORTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AND EXCITEMENT SB FOUR THREE
SEVEN WHICH IS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. AND IT IS ON
THE LOCAL PUBLIC OWNED ELECTRIC
UTILITIES INTEGRATED RESOURCE
PLANNING BY SENATOR WHITEHOUSE
SKI IS PRESENTING IT SINCE THE
TO DO PASSED MOTION AND MISTER
WHITE CASKET WOULD YOU LIKE TO
TELL US ABOUT YOUR BILL THANK
YOU- RESEARCHER AND YOU'RE
RIGHT THIS IS REQUIRES HE'S
INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLANS ARE
SUBMITTED BY THE PUBLICLY
OWNED. UTILITIES TO INCLUDE
DETAILS OF THEIR ELECTRICITY
RATE DESIGNS FOR THE
TRANSPORTATION ELECTRIFICATION
TO CURRENTLY THESE ARE PIECE
ONLY ADDRESS THE LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES AND. DID NOT INCLUDE
THE MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY V.
AND THE SIX FOOT WOULD REQUIRE
THAT SNOWED IN THE ANALYSIS-
THERE'S A ONE TIME COST OF
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR THE ENERGY COMMISSION TO
REVIEW THE RATE DESIGNS AND
ARE. IN OUR PIECE FOR THIS BILL.
TO APPLY AND I WOULD URGE. AND
I WROTE FIRST THANK YOU MISTER
KATHY DO HAVE ANY. WITNESSES I
BELIEVE. NO I DO NOT AND SO
WE'LL GO TO GENERAL PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THERE'S NOBODY
REPORTED TWO OH THREE. SEVEN
ROOM TWENTY FORTIES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR THREE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME WELL NOT
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR THREE
SEVEN THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE. THE COMPANY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO S. B. FOUR THREE
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR THREE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT HAVE A
TICKETS WERE IN OPPOSITION
SEEING ANY QUESTIONS FROM MY
CALL OF MR JONES HAS A
QUESTION. DISTRICT COURT MISTER
CHAIRMAN MISTER CASKEY THANK
YOU I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A
DEFICIT IN THE FUND IT IS
SUPPOSED TO PAY FOR THIS WORK.
IN THE DEFICIT. IS APPARENTLY
ANY IN THE RANGE OF ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR SO I'M
WONDERING WHERE THE COMMISSION.
IS LOOKING AT GETTING THE MONEY
TO PAY FOR THAT. TO CATCH UP ON
THE RESEARCHER FROM THE
ALTERNATIVE AND RENEWABLE. FUEL
AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY FUND
WHICH WILL PROBABLY COVERED THE
SICK. OUT PROJECTED COSTS IN
IT- DENOUNCES POINTS THAT OUT
THAT THAT WILL BE AT THIS IS.
IT'S A IT'S A GOOD PROBLEM TO
HAVE THAT WE'RE HAVING PEOPLE
USE LESS AND LESS ENERGY. AND
THIS FUND HAS A DEFICIT EACH
YEAR IT'S ONE OF THE- YEAH
THOSE SHINING LIGHTS OF STATE
GOVERNMENT IS THAT WE WERE
DOING A BETTER JOB. SO WE HAVE
LESS MONEY IN THE FUND BECAUSE
CONSUMERS ARE DOING YOU KNOW.
WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO SO
THAT'S- THE BILL ALLOWS THAT
FLEXIBILITY TO USES- THIS IS A
TECHNOLOGY FUND. MISTER TAYLOR
I WOULD MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE
A MOTION IS FORECAST WE'D LIKE
TO MAKE CLOTHES. HAIR TONIGHT
BOTH. ALL RIGHT WE THIS IS A TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY FIXING THE
SENATE FOR. MISTER CHIEF
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATE BILL FOUR THREE SEVEN MY
CENTER MY COUNTY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
CENTER PORTANTINO HI. YOU KNOW
HI BATES. IT'S NO BRADFORD.
JONES NO JONES NO PROBLEM-
AIRED BY LAYERED HI MY COUNTY
HI CASKEY ARE CURRENTLY THREE
TWO. THE BILL IS CURRENTLY AT
THREE TWO WE WILL PLACE IT ON
CALL FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS WE
WILL MOVE TO HIDE- IS LEYVA HAS
THREE BILLS SENATOR LEYVA HAS
THREE BILLS- STARTING WITH SB
FIFTY THREE AN UNSOLICITED
IMAGES. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE AND- SHE'S WAY
PRESENTATION AND THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES YOU KNOW
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY
THREE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIFTY THREE. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY THREE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIFTY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE'LL GO TO OUR POSITION
OF SB FIFTY THREE. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE WHO TO ME THAT THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIFTY THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I THINK IT
WAS I THINK WE DID SUPPORT
LET'S GO TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION NEXT MAKE SURE WE
COVER EVERYTHING SUPPORTER%
OPPOSITION OF SB. FIFTY THREE.
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT ON SB
FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL
OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB
FIFTY THREE ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS OF MY COLLEAGUES. SB
FIFTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING SB THREE SEVENTY TWO.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY FLEET
PURCHASING ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
ZERO EMISSIONS VEHICLES. THE
AWKWARD WAY PRESENTATION THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL START
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH
THE GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT.
THERE'S NOBODY HERE THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX THREE SEVEN TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SEVEN
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE'LL MOVE COMPOSITION OF
SB THREE SEVENTY TWO THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
OPPOSED SB THREE SEVENTY TWO.
SEVENTY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB THREE
SEVEN TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE SEVEN TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
SIX I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE TAKE
IT'S IMPORTANT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES ON THREE SEVENTY
TWO AND SEEING NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE SEVENTY TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
LABOR LABOR ON LABOR RELATED
LIABILITIES- THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL START
THE PUBLIC COMMON ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE-
IN TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE LOTTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE COMMENTING QUEUE LINE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MY WRITER MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION OF
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN STARTING
IN THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
HERE OPPOSED TO SOMEBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. AND MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN TWO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE COMMENT JIM QUEUE LINE
TWO OH SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THANK YOU DANNY CURT WITH
CALIFORNIA CONFERENCE OF
CARPENTERS I MISS THAT SUPPORT
BUT I AM IN SUPPORT OF SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION SB SEVEN TWENTY
SEVEN AND- THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION- WE WILL PUT
SB SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN ON
SUSPENSE MISCON WATER AND
MISTER BRADFORD- HERE MR CHIEF
CONSERVATIVE TO CALL. MINUS
BEFORE THIRTY SEVEN Y. CASKEY.
FEDERAL FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
MCCASKEY TO MOTIONS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR CURRENT VOTE
HIS THREE TWO CHAIR VOTING I'D
BUY SURE VOTING NO CENTER
BRADFORD. EFFORT BY SENATOR TOM
LOGGER HI FROM LOGGER ON BOTH
SIDES TO. SETTLE IS OUT ON A
FIVE TO VOTE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL MOVE ON TO. OUR NEXT
BILL BY SENATOR ALAN. SB SIXTY
SIX CALIFORNIA COUNCIL ON THE
FUTURE OF TRANSPORTATION
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. DOCTORS WAY
PRESENTATION IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. WE WILL START OUR
PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. BUT IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIXTY SIX. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH O SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX PLEASE
PRESS WHAT. ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION TO THE SP SIXTY SIX-
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SB SIXTY SIX THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
OPPOSED TO SIXTY SIX MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIXTY SIX. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT OPPOSITION
OF SB SIXTY SIX SYNCING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIXTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WILL MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT BILL BY SENATOR
ALLEN WHICH IS S. B. TWO THREE
FIVE ON INDUSTRIAL CAMPUSES
EMERGENCY MATTER. PLEASE WAY
PRESENTATION IT IS A SSPENSE
CANDIDATE- NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
AND WE'LL START PUBLIC
TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE WILL MOVE TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SEVENTY THEIR MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THREE FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO THREE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ONE
COMMENT THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DANIEL CANDOR
KAISER ON BEHALF OF CHARLOTTE'S
WEB PROG SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
VERGEER I THOUGHT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL MOVE ON
OPPOSITION WILL START THE
OPPOSITION RIGHT HERE IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NOBODY HERE MOVED
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY- SING OVER
THE ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
IF YOU QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINES. SUPPOSED TO S. B.
TWO THREE FIVE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWO THREE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF S. B. TWO THREE FIVE. TINA
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO THREE
FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE. MOVIE
BONTA SB FOUR FIVE NINE- BY
CENTER ALLEN ON THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. WE WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENT IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE WILL
MOVE TO THE TWENTY FORTY THIRD
COMPANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINES IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
FIVE NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. FOUR FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR FIVE NINE- THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE OPPOSERS HAVE A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE NINE
OPPOSED SB. FOUR FIVE NINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
FIVE NINE IN THERE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOUR FIVE NINE GO
TO SUSPENSE. SB FORTY THREE BY
CENTER AROUND SENTENCING AND
RESENTENCING TO REMOVE
ENHANCEMENTS. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND WE. NOT
EVERY PRIMARY WITNESSES SO WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO GENERAL PUBLIC
COMMENT AND SUPPORT TESTIMONY
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE AND
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR EIGHTY THREE BY SENATE
AROUND. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHT THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NOT IN YOU. R. I. WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION BEFORE THREE
FIVE AROUND- THERE'S NOBODY
REPORTED A THREE THIS NUMBER
ROOM TO FORTY NINERS ARE ON THE
LINE. OPPOSE TO B. FOR THREE.
THANK YOU IF HE WISHES OUT. TO
S. B. FOUR EIGHT THREE THREE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVING OFFERED SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION TESTIMONY FOR SB
FORTY THREE. ENCINO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FORTY THREE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON B SIX
SIX FOUR. MY CENTER ALLEN ON
HOSPICE HOSPICE LICENSURE. IT
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION- NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO OPEN UP
GENERAL COMMON HERE S. AND ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE- THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY FOR SUPPORT. THERE'S NO
SUPPORTERS IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
SIX SIX FOUR BY SENATOR OUT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB SIX SIX FOUR
I'M SORRY SB SIX SIX FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE COMMENTS LINE THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. OTHER THE PULP
OF REDONDO BEACH. WHARTON THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT REMOVED
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SIX FOUR-
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATED OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIX SIX FOUR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX SIX FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU I WOULD TAKE
IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND SING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX SIX
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVIE
ON SB SEVEN FIVE TWO ON
ELECTIONS DISCLOSURE OF
CONTRIBUTIONS. BY CENTER ALLEN-
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SO WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. ASSEMBLY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FIVE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES SO WILL
OPEN UP IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. NOBODY
AROUND TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FIVE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. VERY
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN FIFTY TWO INCH
EMAIL QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SEVEN FIFTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. LEVINE S. B. SIXTY
NINE BY SENATOR MCGUIRE ON THE
NORTH COAST RAILROAD AUTHORITY.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SO WE'LL
MOVE RIGHT TO OUR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
SEVEN ZERO TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
QUEUE LINE ONE HUNDRED PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS BATTLING OUR CAMILLE
GRAMMER. WARREN COUNTY IMPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT REMOVED OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTY NINE- THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO WE'LL SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE IS NOT.
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE IS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SB
SIXTY NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
AS B. SIX NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMON G. Q.
I. NINETY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A REQUEST-
CONSTABLE TO ASK YOUR STAFF TO
PRODUCE THE GENDERS IN THE
ORDER IN WHICH YOU'RE GOING TO
CALL BILLS WE ARE VERY HARD TO
FOLLOW- THE WAY THAT- THE
AGENDA THEY ARE CURRENTLY
READING. I'M SORRY. YEAH IT IS
IN THE DAILY FILE AND ON THE
WEBSITE IN FILE ORDER SO- WE'RE
ALREADY DOING THAT- SO DO YOU
HAVE A COMMENT ON SB SIXTY
NINE. SINCE THE NEGATIVES WERE
OVER THE THIRTY RIGHT AWAY. I
GUESS NOT- SO WE'VE TAKEN BOTH
SURPRISE THAT THE LAST ONE
MODERATOR. YES I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT SINGKIL ALL
RIGHT THERE'S NO FURTHER
COMMENTS ON SB SIXTY NINE
SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
SIXTY NINE WITH A SUSPENSE. WE
WILL MOVE TO ITEM S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN BY COMMITTEE MEMBER
MISTER JONES ON OFF HIGHWAY
VEHICLES HE HAS GRACIOUSLY WAY
PRESENTATION BUT HE DOES HAVE
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OF SB TWO TWO SEVEN ON HIGHWAY
VEHICLES OFF HIGHWAY VEHICLES
WE HAVE TWO PRIMARY SUPPORT
WITNESSES- MISTER TERRY MCHALE
FROM THE COALITION FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS. AND THEN ALSO MISTER
JAMES LOMBARDO WITH CALIFORNIA
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS ASSOCIATION
CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE THREE MINUTES
AND WE WILL START WITH MR
MCHALE IF YOU WERE THERE. YEAH
MISTER CHAIRMAN. MCHALE ARENDT
RECONSIDERS I REPRESENT A
COALITION OF OFF HIGHWAY
WRITERS. BUILDER NOT INCLUDE
THE COST EXPENSE OF THE
EMBATTLED ONLY TO PROGRAM
BEYOND WHAT IT DOES TODAY.
ACTRESS SIGNIFICANT REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF NON COMPLIANCE.
CONTINUE TO PUT IN PLACE A
SYSTEM THAT GENERATES FEES TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
REGULATE RIDERSHIP TO
RESTRICTED AND CONTROLLED
BURNS. OFFICE BUILT COMPETITIVE
VEHICLES WILL NOT BE REGISTERED
AND THE END RESULT WILL BE A
LOSS OF FUNDING FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
FUNDING AND MINISTRATION.
ASKREN I THOUGHT. ALL RIGHT ARE
YOU MISTER THE MARTYR. YES
MEMBERS OF COMMITTEES AND
TRANSFERS HAVE CALIFORNIA HOLD
ON ONE SECOND IS A MICROPHONE.
ALL RIGHT GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS A COMMITTEE JAMES
ON BOTTOM HALF THAT CALIFORNIA
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER FOUR HUNDRED.
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. OUR MOTORCYCLE
DEALERS HAVE HIM BEEN HIT VERY
HARD BY THE CODE JUST LIKE
RESTAURANTS OR PEOPLE DRIVEN
BUSINESS THEY HAVE TO COME INTO
OUR STORE TO PURCHASE OUR
PRODUCT. AND WE'VE BEEN SHUT
DOWN FOR SIX MONTHS WITH
VIRTUALLY NO SALES- THAT WOULD
NOW THAT THIS DID THE
DEALERSHIPS ARE OPENING UP FOR
BEING RESTRICTED AS NUMBER OF
FEAR OF PEOPLE THAT CAN COME IN
TO DO THOSE PURCHASES- THE- OFF
ROAD- VEHICLES HAVE BEEN
RESTRICTED BY BY AIR RESOURCES
BOARD WE ELIMINATED 93% OF THE
SALE OF TWO STROKE MOTORCYCLES.
THERE'S ONLY A SMALL AMOUNT
LEFT THAT 7% AND THAT'S LIMITED
TO PEOPLE THAT COMPETITIVELY
RACE. AS SPIKE PEOPLE THAT WANT
TO BE IN THE IN THE LONG BEACH
GRAND PRIX OR THE LAGUNA SECA
THEY HAVE TO BUY THESE VEHICLES
IN PRACTICE IN ORDER TO GO IN
AND BE INVOLVED THESE
MOTORCYCLE RACES. IT'S ABOUT A
TWENTY SIX POINT THREE LOSS OF
SALES FOR MOTORCYCLE DEALERS
MOTORCYCLE DEALERS ARE SMALL
TEN TO THIRTY PEOPLE. S.
AWESOME AND PART OF OUR
FUNCTION MOTORCYCLE RACER SICK
BY TWO BIKES THEY HAVE A RACE
BIKE AND NEVER PRACTICED. THEY
BUY PARTS FOR THOSE THINGS
TIRES OUT OTHER THINGS. SO IT'S
A IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
DESERVE. THESE RACES ARE AN
ATTAINMENT AREAS OF SMALL
COMPLIANCE IN SMALL COMMUNITIES
THAT DEPEND ON THOSE RACES FOR
BUSINESS AT MOTELS RESTAURANTS
AND- GAS STATIONS. SO IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT WE'VE RESTRICTED
THIS BILL VERY VERY TIGHTLY TO
COMPETITIVE RACERS. AND WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO IT IF
YOU COULD PASS THIS BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR MEMBERS. THANK
YOU MISS THE MURDER OF HER FROM
THE TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL
NOT GO TO GENERAL PUBLIC
COMMENTED SUPPORT. THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S ONLY ROOM TWENTY. FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN. SUPPORT OF S. B.
C. TWO SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
TO SPEAK INTO OF S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. IN OPPOSITION WILL
OPEN UP A PUBLIC COMMENT IN
THIS ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED. TO SP TWO TWO SEVEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. VETERANS I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
TWO SEVEN MISTER JONES WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE ON
THE PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL
I'LL REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT
THIS IS THE SAME AS MY S. B.
TEN TWENTY FOUR. YES I CAN SEND
OUT OF THE SENATE LAST YEAR I
PASSED THE ASSEMBLY AT THE END
OF THE SESSION UNFORTUNATELY
DIDN'T MAKE IT BACK. IN TIME
FOR CAN CURRENT SERVER IT WILL
BE ON THE GOVERNOR'S DESK IN A
DONE DEAL BY NOW. BUT WE ARE
GETTING SUPPORT FROM AROUND THE
STATE INCLUDING A HARLEY
DAVIDSON OF GLENDALE. SO THIS
IS IMPORTANT STATEWIDE- BILL
AND LOOK FORWARD TO AN AYE VOTE
FROM THE COMMITTEE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SINGH NO
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
DAVIDSON GLENDALE. THIS IS. HI
I'M JUST ONE. EXACTLY IT WAS A
GLENDALE CALIFORNIA GLENDALE
ARIZONA. IT WOULD BE CALIFORNIA
SURCHARGE CALIFORNIA'S REPORTS
COMMUTER IN THE STATE OF VERY
POOR THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
JONES I APPRECIATED VERY GOOD
WORK ALL RIGHT SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO TO SEVEN. GO
TO SUSPENSE MISTER JONES- TWO
OTHER BILLS FIFTY FOUR SEVENTY
FOUR AND FISHING AND HUNTING
ANNUAL COUNTRY COMBINED HUNTING
AND FISHING LICENSING HE IS WAY
PRESENTATION AS WELL OR NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO.
OH THREE IN SUPPORT OF OUT OF
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE IN SUPPORT FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IT'S
SORT OF SB. FOUR SEVEN ZERO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SOME. OF AS FOR SEVEN ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE COMMENTING Q. IT'LL JUST BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THAT Y. NUMBER.
TRYING TO SIXTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ACCORDING TO REMEMBERS
JERRY DESMOND ON BEHALF OF
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I ALSO HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THAT NEXT LINE
NUMBER. WHITE ONE TENDENCIES GO
AHEAD. JERRY HABRAKEN BUT THE
CONGRESSIONAL SPORTSMEN'S
FOUNDATION HERE TODAY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE ANYBODY
FROM THE GLENDALE FISHING
ASSOCIATION. JUST CHECKING JUST
CHECKING ALL RIGHT I HAVEN'T
REPRESENT YOU COULD
REPRESENTATIVES HAVE BEEN
TAKING THE SUPPORT REMOVED
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE SEVENTY
BY MR JONES- THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT. SIR
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
ACTUALLY ME OPPOSITION- SIR
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION. TO SB.
FOUR SEVENTY. MODERATOR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO US BEFORE SEVENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
C. NO COMMENTS OF OPPOSITION
AND SING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
BEFORE SEVENTY. WILL GO TWO
SUSPECTS. WILL MOVE ON TO SB
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
JONES ON JUVENILES HEALTH
INFORMATION SUMMARY. AND
PSYCHOTROPIC MEDICATION THIS IS
SB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT THERE ARE
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE'LL START WITH PUBLIC COMMENT
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE AND THERE'S NOBODY HERE.
ABOUT A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TO
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOT GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TO
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT AND SINGLE QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FIVE TWENTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE SENATOR DOLLY IS THREE
BILLS BEFORE STARTING WITH SB
TWO TWO NINE HUNDRED PEOPLE
HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
AND GRANTS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION SO OFTEN OF THE
PUBLIC COMMENT FORTY TWO OR
THREE WITH SUPPORT TESTIMONY
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN SUPPORT.
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SIGNAL WHEN THERE WILL MOVE TO
OUR PHONE LINE MODERATE IS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO TWO NINE USES.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENTS IN Q. ALL
RIGHT. WE WILL NOW THAT
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WILL
OPEN UP THE OPPOSITION THIS
MONEY HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SP
TWO TWO NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. TWO TWO NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION A TWO
TWO NINE ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE BILL SB
TWO TWO NINE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB FIVE FIVE
ZERO. ON LEGISLATURE EMPLOYMENT
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION AND
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE
TWELVE IS FIVE FIVE ZERO.
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE FIVE ZERO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FIVE ZERO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
MOVES OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
FIVE ZERO THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. THERE'S NOBODY HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE SIR
ANYONE A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE ZERO
C. NINE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. FIVE
FIVE ZERO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE FIVE ZERO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS
THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE COMING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE- MR LEARN
HAS A QUESTION I DON'T KNOW I
JUST HAVE A COMMENT I BELIEVE
THAT SENATOR DOLLY WAS SEVERELY
HAZED IN THE TWO PREVIOUS
COMMITTEES ON THIS BILL AND I
CAN SEE WHY HE WAVED
PRESENTATION. AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THE MAY DAY PICNIC AT THE
DALI RANCH WAS A HUGE SUCCESS.
EVEN THE CITY OF GLENDALE IS
NEUTRALIZE. ALL RIGHT- HAVEN'T
HEARD THOSE COMMENTS AND SEE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE FIVE ZERO
CHAU TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON TO
MISTER DOLLARS SB FIVE NINETY
TWO ON FISH AND WILDLIFE
WORKING GROUP'S CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES CENTER REPORT. THIS
IS ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN%
SUPPORT- PRIMARY WITNESSES SO
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY REPORTED TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE- THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINETY TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE NINE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVE AN OFFER THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR SUPPORT WILL OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OPPOSITION
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THEIR
COMPANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS ANYONE OPPOSED SB
FIVE NINETY TWO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FIVE NINE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. DISPENSARY OWNERS. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
QUEUE LINE EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS A BIT AND WE
LOCK IT CALIFORNIA AND I AM SO
SORRY I DIALED NINE ZERO TOO
LATE- BUT I WANTED TO- MEDIAN
SUPPORT AND FIVE NINETY TWO ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
NINETY TWO AT CHINO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS BILL SO
GO TO SUSPENSE. BEYOND THE
SENATOR NIELSEN'S TO BILLS
STARTING WITH F. B. TWO THREE
TWO ON EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT POLICIES AND
PRACTICES. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE A GOOD SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO WE'LL START WITH
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
FORTY TWO OR THREE. AND THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE TO TESTIFY WILL GO TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO THREE TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO THREE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL MOVE TO
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE TO THREE
TO TURN- PROBABLY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NO
MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
WISHING TO OPPOSE SB TWO THREE
TWO BY SENATOR NIELSEN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWO THREE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ARE
HAVE A TAKE IT'S IMPORTANT
OPPOSE OPPORTUNITIES ON SB
THREE TWO THREE TWO INSING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB TWO THREE
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. YES
BEFORE NINETY ONE BY SENATOR
NIELSEN ON CIGARETTES AND
TOBACCO PRODUCTS LICENSING ACT
OF TWO THOUSAND THREE- THIS IS
A SUSPENSE KENNEDY AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION. AND WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT RIGHT HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE AND THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN SUPPORT THERE'S
NO MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT. WATER IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR NINETY ONE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR NINE ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
COMMENT GQ RIGHT INTO THIRTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. OUR BOARD
REPORT OF THE VIDEO FORTY ONE.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL JUST TELL US
WHO YOU ARE. SMOKERS. OKAY I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AND CAL ALL RIGHT THAT WAS
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT I LOST
MYSELF SUPPORT SUPPORT LET'S GO
TO OPPOSITION- WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR OPPOSITION
OF SB FOUR NINETY ONE THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OF A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE OPPOSED TO. SP FOUR
NINETY ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. FOUR NINETY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
COMMENTING Q. ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT MY NUMBERS. BY ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. BERMAN
SUPPORT OF FOUR EIGHTY ONE AND
I AM COMMITTEE KEY GUY FROM LOS
ANGELES BUT I'M ALSO-
REPRESENTING AND I THINK IT'S
FAMILIES TEAM L. Y. HI
COMMITTEE. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE THE RIGHT DEAL. ALL RIGHT
RAZA IS BUILT AROUND. THE US WE
ARE THE WRONG BILL BUT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS YEAH
WE'RE ON SB FOUR NINETY ONE
OPPOSITION MODERATOR KICKBOXING.
THANK YOU I HAVE TWO MORE
COMMENTS THANK YOU IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE NEXT Y.
NUMBER. LONG TERM INVESTORS THE
STATURE. OUR SYSTEM IN OUR NEXT
COMMENTS FROM FLYING TO THIRTY
NINE. BOATWRIGHT NINE ONE
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE ONE NINE THREE. I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION THE REST BEFORE
NINETY ONE NINETEEN OF
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION IS BEFORE
NINETY ONE WITH A SUSPENSE
MOVIE THE SENATOR- BURGLARS
THREE BILLS BEFORE US. STARTING
WITH SB TWO FORTY ONE ON CIVIL
ACTIONS THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE OR NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES WILL OPEN UP THE
PUBLIC COMMENTS. BY YEAR AND
FORTY TWO OR THREE AND WE SEE
NOBODY TO FOR US WILL MOVE TO
TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S NOBODY
THERE WE SHALL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO FORTY ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO FOUR ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL NOT OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO FORTY ONE WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE. NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TWO FOUR ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWO FOUR ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT
SEVEN COMMENTING Q. IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THE FIRST
LINE. CERTIFIED YOUR HEADLINE
NINETY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME'S KELLY SHAMING CERTIFIED
SHORTHAND REPORTER NUMBER ONE
THREE FOUR SEVEN THANK THANK CO
FOUNDER PROTECT YOUR RECORD
PROJECT STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TWO
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I NINETY NINE PLEASE GLAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS MICHAEL HAMBLY
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTER
NUMBER ONE FOUR ONE ONE FOUR
AND PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTERS ASSOCIATION ON
BEHALF OF THE ENTIRE SITUATION
WE STAND IN OPPOSITION TO U. S.
B. TWO FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
RYAN TO TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE MY NAME IS
KIMBERLY HERE FOR PRESIDENT OF
THE PROTECT YOUR RECORD
PROJECTS THE ENTIRE NUMBER ONE
ONE THREE SEVEN Q. AND WE STAND
IN OPPOSITION. TO CORDY ONE
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU RYAN CHIU FORTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED PUBLIC EMPLOYEES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I'M TO
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
CHARLOTTE MCGUIRE CALIFORNIA
CERTIFIED SHORTHAND REPORTER
NINETY SEVEN NINETY TWO BUDGET
STIRRED CONFESSIONAL REPORTER
FROM ANALOG CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
SB TWO FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AYE TO FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS TO
EMBRACE I'M CALIFORNIA'S CSR
NUMBER THIRTY THREE TWENTY ONE
AND AN OFFICIAL REPORTER FOR
THE NORTHEAST DISTRICT OF
CALIFORNIA I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU VRY ONE FIFTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
PROPOSAL NAME WITH CALIFORNIAI WENT CALIFORNIA COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSED. TO FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU I WON SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SIX
SEVEN. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKING THE
SPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
FORTY ONE FIFTEEN OF QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION A SPEECH TO FORTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING ON
THE S. B. FOR TWENTY FIVE
SENATOR UMBERG ON UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT HEARING FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SEE NO ONE HERE TO
TESTIFY WILL MOVE TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR TWENTY. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK INTO. OF SB FOUR
TWO ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT Y. NUMBER. AND OUR
COMMENTERS FROM LINE TO FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS ANNA MARIA AND I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE AND SUPPORT
SB. FOUR EIGHTY ONE. OKAY THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
TWENTY. SERRANO SB FOUR TWENTY-
IS THERE ANYONE OPPOSED TO FOR
TWENTY THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. SEVENTY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE AS OPPOSED SB FOUR TWENTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AS BEFORE
TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
TWENTY AND I SEE NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AS BEFORE TWENTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE ON SB FIVE
SIXTY NINE BY SENATOR UMBERG ON
PUBLIC CONTRACTS FOR THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH ENTITIES THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION. AND
WE WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
DIFFERENT PAYMENT TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX
NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION TO
THE SP FIVE SIXTY NINE THERE'S
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THIRTY ONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY NO- MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SB FIVE SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN. TO SB FIVE SIX NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHTS WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OPPORTUNITIES AND THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE SIXTY
NINE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO SENATOR ARCHER LET IS S.
B. TWO FOUR FOUR ON LITHIUM ION
BATTERIES AND ILLEGAL DISPOSAL
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
THE OFFICE WAY PRESENTATION
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC COMMENT
IN FROM ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY
AND THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TWO FOUR FOUR.
THANK YOU YOU WISH IS AND- OF
S. B. TWO FOUR FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO FOUR FOUR THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM. OPPOSED SB
TWO FOUR FOUR THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB TWO FOUR FOUR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TWO FOUR
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE. TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO FOUR FOUR
THERE'S NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWO FOUR FOUR FOUR MOVED TO
SUSPEND TO MOVE ON TO DOCTOR
PAN. SB THREE OH SIX ON
SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED DISEASE
TESTING. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE DOCTOR'S WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESS INSTANCE SUPPORTS WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY
HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY HERE TO TESTIFY
OF A ROOM FOUR THERE'S NO BUT
THERE TO TELL. MODERATOR ANYONE
ON PHONE LINE IT'S A POOR OF S.
B. THREE OH SIX. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK SUPPORT TO
ADD. THREE OCEAN PLEASED ONE
AND THEN ZERO I THIS TIME. I
HAVE ONE. Q. I FORTY FOUR P. GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON FUTURE
NUMBER SO THE MATTER LIKE HAS
THE LOOK AT. CALLING ON THE OF
NAY APPROACH CALIFORNIA CAL-
MIDWIVES FIFTY TRONG THE COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW TO
OPPOSITION THERE PRIMARY
WITNESSES OPPOSITION MOST OF
ANY ROOM FOR TWO- THREE THE
SUPPOSED OR SOMEONE IN TWENTY
OPPOSED. MODERATE HEARING ON
THE FOR LINE OPPOSE TO SPEAK
HOURS. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OP. TO A THREE OR SIX
PLEASE. ONE AND THEN. AT TIME.
I CURRENTLY NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT TAKEN SUPPORT
NOW. OF A SPEECH UPSET. THERE'S
NO QUESTION FOR CALL SO THAT.
SB THREE SIX SO TO SUSPEND. I
HAVE TWO BILLS. A NECKSB THREE
EIGHTY SO ON P. OFFICER SHOULD.
A SIR EDUCATION PHYSICIST CAN
I'VE PRESENT. I HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND SOME. WILL OPEN
UP THE GENERAL TIME. AND NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE SUPPORT
SB EIGHTY BY PORT. ELEVEN ROOM
FOUR. MODERATE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE I IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHTY. THANK YOU IF YOU WERE
TO SPEAK SEPT OF AN SPEECH
EIGHT SEVEN. PRAY ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE COMMENTING Q. IT WILL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT MY
NUMBERS. RIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARON MEMBERS ONLY ARE SITTING
CANNELLA BELIEVED CITIES IN
SUPPORT. YOU THANK YOU I AM NO
FURTHER COMMENT YOU AT THE TIME
RIGHT WE WERE GOING OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE EIGHTY SEVEN- THERE
NO PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL OPEN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSE SB. THREE SEVEN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN UP
TO SB THREE EIGHT SEVEN PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I DO EVERYONE COMMENTING Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT Y. NUMBER. HOW MUCH IS
GOING TO BE FROM ONE TO SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS PLANNED
ENOUGH ABOUT THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF APOLOGIES I
COULDN'T DIAL IN FAST ENOUGH ON
THE SUPPORT SIDE THEY WERE
CALLING IN THE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU I HAVE FURTHER. THANK YOU
AT THE TIME HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO
NOT OF US THREE SEVEN THING THE
QUESTIONS FROM MY- TO OBJECT SB.
THREE SEVEN. PORTANTINO AGO TO
SUSPEND. SB FIVE SIXTY TWO ALSO
PORTANTINO. ON HEALTHCARE
COVERAGE PERVASIVE DISORDER OR
AUTISM. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WE HAVE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WILL OPEN
UP THE GENERAL COMMENT. IN TWO
OR THREE THERE'S A HERE. THIRTY
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY NOW. WE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINE PLEASE
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
SIXTY TWO NOW WOULD BE THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT TO
ASK THREE. FIVE SIX TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NEVER OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO. EMORY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION THERE'S NOBODY
REPORTED TO- THREE SEVENTY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
PLEASE SKIP ANYONE OPPOSED SB.
FIVE SIX TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT HAVING TICKETS
WERE IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
SIXTY TWO BY PORTANTINO. YOU
KNOW QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FIVE SIXTY TWO. SPENT MOVING
ONTO CENTER LET HAS BUILT FOR
US. FOR START WITH SB THREE
NINE ON A PLANE DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT CONFERENCE. PLAN IS
A CANDIDATE THE OFFERS WERE
PRESS THANK YOU AND ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESS BUT WE WILL
OPEN UP THE PUBLIC AND OF SB
THREE FIVE LETTER. IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF ASH THREE
NINETY PER PRESS AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YOU DON'T CARE IF
IT'S BECAUSE OR FAST SO COME.
PLAN I CURRENTLY HAVE NO CRIME
CHANGE. ALL RIGHT I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE CHECKED IN WITH
FORTY TWO THREE IN WHICH IN
WITH FOUR. THERE'S NONE WITH TO
OFFICE TO S. B. THREE- THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM. TO FORTY. AND IF THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE OPPOSE TO
SPEAK NINE NOW BE THERE ARE.
THANK IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OP
TO A B. NINETY PLEASE PER ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT MISTER LEONARD
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A CALM. IT
WILL BE BRING. OF THE INNER.
SAYS THERE WERE BE SO. COST
PRESSURES. IN IMPLEMENTING THAT
BILL THAT WOULD BE DUE TO
RECESSION NOT THE BILL AND THIS
TIME WE WOULD ACTUALLY PLAN
FORWARD. SO THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO COMMENT THANK
YOU MISTER WHERE. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE HAD ARE COMMON THERE'S NO
OTHER COMMENTS WE'VE HAD ARE
FOR AND AGAINST OPPORTUNITIES.
SAYING NO OTHER QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
NINETY. PELOTAS FOR MOVE ON TO.
SENATOR LAYERED SB FOUR ONE
EIGHT ONE ZERO RISE PLAN
DATABASE. THIS IS CANADA THE
CENTER WAY PER. ON- PRIMARY
WHEN SO OF UP COMMENT. IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. WILL GO TO FROM TO
FORTY THEIR NOBODY THERE
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE AND- OF THIS BEFORE. THANK
YOU YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF ASH FOUR EIGHTEEN
PRAY ONE THEN AFTER TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO. CHANGE OUR
WELL NOW THAT OFFICE. NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO ABOUT ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S NO
HERE WITHOUT A ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THE NOBODY MY ARE. ON THE
PHONE LINE OF SAID BEFORE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE TO SPEAK
IN NAPA. TO BEFORE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE PER ONE AND THEN AFTER
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
HAVE BEEN TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION REST BEFORE
EIGHTEEN. TINO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FOUR EIGHTEEN. WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE WILL MOVE TEST BEFORE
FIFTY SIX. BY SENATOR LAYER ON
FIRE PREVENTION. FOREST HEALTH
ACTION PLAN REPORTS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THE SENATORS WAY PRESENTATION.
AND WILL OPEN UP FOR THE COMMON
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR FIFTY SIX.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR FOR SIX
PLEASED ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT JIM Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GOOD OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE
FIFTY SIX- THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND THERE'S NOBODY
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE THAT
HAVE ANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION. TO SB
FOUR FIFTY SIX BY SENATOR
LETTER. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
FOUR FIVE SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
LEHRER THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE HE'S WAY
PRESENTATION. AND NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY ON ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE ON BEFORE
NINETY SIX. SEEING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM SIGNAL IN A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONEON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE SIX.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ONE COMMENT CHEN Q. IT'LL JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT MY
NUMBERS. THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS.
MONTEREY AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
HELLO TRYING TO FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN SENATORS I AM
DOCTOR ARE STRICTLY SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF THAT'S BEFORE NINETY
SIX ON BEHALF OF THE SPONSORING
AGENCY THE SNTA CRUZ COUNTY
FOR CONTROL AND WATER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT LONG
SEVEN. SENATOR LAYERED MEASURE
PROVIDE THE ONLY MEANS BY WHICH
ARE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
HAVE ANY HOPE OF SECURING PLOT
PROTECTION WE WERE ISOLATED
INFRASTRUCTURE WE URGE THE
COMMITTEES PAS OF SUSPENSE I'LL
ACTION ON THE BILL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU WE'RE
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I HAVE
ONE MORE COMMENT FROM MY EIGHTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH
HENRY LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA SAVE
LAFAYETTE LIVABLE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT OF FOUR NINETY SIX.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION NOTICE
BEFORE NINETY SIX THING NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND LET'S GO
TO THIS ROOMTHERE'S NOBODY
HERE IN OPPOSITION AS BEFORE
NINETY SIX ON FLOOD CONTROL BY
MR LAYERED THING NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE HAS
BEFORE NINETY SIX. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB FOUR NINE SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE LITTLE
COMMENTING Q. ALL RIGHT WITH
CHECK IN SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM. MANY MEMBERS HERE GOOD
SEEING NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB FOUR NINETY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVE ON TO SENATOR
STERN HAS. SHOW FOR NINETEEN
WAS PULLED WITH S. B. FOUR FIVE
EIGHTY TWO ON CLIMATE EMERGENCY
MITIGATION SAFE RESTORATION AND
CHEST RESILIENCY ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. BY SENATOR STERN
HAS WAY PRESENTATION THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE I SEE NO
ONE. WILL GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE THERE
MODERATOR COULD YOU QUEUE UP
ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO BY SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHT TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WOULD OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO- NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. FIVE
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE EIGHT TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT HAVING
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION FOR SB
FIVE EIGHTY TWO IT'S EMAIL
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
EIGHTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB SEVEN NINETY BY
SENATOR STERN ON WILD LIFE
CONNECTIVITY MITIGATION
CREDITS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION. AND THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES BUT WILL OPEN
A PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE FORTY TWO OR THREE DAYS
HOW MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN NINE ZERO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN NINE ZERO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
HAVE ONE COMMENTING Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT Y.
NUMBERS. BY ONE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BALKANS OFFICE ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF THOUSAND
OAKS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN NINETY
START HERE ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY OPPOSED.
HERE THERE'S NO MINIMUM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE HEARING ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB SEVEN
NINETY BY SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH IS PICKING
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. YES THIS IS A M. Y.
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD- I
MISSED THE CALL AGAIN I MEANT
TO CALL IN IN SUPPORT OF A BEST
OF SEVEN NINETY I WILL ADMIT
THAT SORRY. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVING TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF SB SEVEN NINETY BY SENATOR
STERN INCHING NO QUESTIONS BY
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SEVEN NINETY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB FOUR
FIVE ONE BY SENATOR DODD. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THERE
ARE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WILL OPEN UP
PUBLIC COMMENT IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE. THIS IS ON
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING A
PILOT PROGRAM AND IT IS AN
URGENCY MATTER. THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN FORTY TWO OR THREE
IN SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIVE ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIVE ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE
WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT WHEN I
MOVED OPPOSITION THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
WILL MOVE TO THIS ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE. TWENTY FORTY THERE'S
NOBODY THERE MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED US
BEFORE FIVE ONE BY SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR FIVE
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVE A GOOD SUPPORT OPPOSITION
OF THIS BEFORE FIVE ONE IT'S
ENOUGH QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION IS
BEFORE FIVE ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. SB EIGHT TWENTY IS A
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS
COMMITTEE BILL. ON HORSERACING
STATE DESIGNATED FARES
ALLOCATION OF REVENUES GROSS
RECEIPTS FOR SALES AND USE TAX.
THE CHAIR HAS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES PRIMER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT BUT WILL
OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
FORTY TWO OR THREE. SEE NO ONE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
SUPPORT TEAM NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN SPORT WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE MODERATORS FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT TWENTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENTS IN Q. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION- THERE NO
PRIMER WITNESSES SO WE'LL GO
HERE TO FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM.
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATE WHICH QUEUE UP
ANYONE OPPOSED SB EIGHT TWENTY
ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB EIGHT TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY THERE'S
NO FOR COLLEGE THAT OF THAT
WILL GO TO. MOVIE ON THE SAN
CONSOLE IS TO BILLS FIRST ONE
S. B. FIFTY TWO ONE GOVERNMENT
DEMO. AND REFUGEE IF AGE OFF OF
M. AND IF. THIS IS CAN EIGHTY
AWARE. AND THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO WE WILL GO TO
PUBLIC COMMENT IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH THREE THERE'S NOBODY
HERE SOMEBODY IN ROOM FOUR
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOUR FIVE TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I DO HAVE ONE COMMENTER IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT Y. NUMBERS. AND OUR COMIC
COMES FROM ONE TO SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M YES I JUST
WANTED TO LET YOU KNOW THAT I'M
SUPPORTING SB. SORRY ABOUT-
CASH- MY GOODNESS SORRY BOUT
THAT. SB FOUR FIFTY TWO
SPELMAN'S. HELLO MY GOODNESS
I'M SORRY I JUST LAST YEAR ALL
RIGHT WHAT'S YOUR NAME. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON THANK
YOU DOESN'T COUNT. MARRERO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WAS IT OPPOSITION AROSE
BEFORE FIFTY TWO THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM. NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IS THERE ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE THIS
BEFORE FIFTY TWO. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. FOUR FIVE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
TINO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE BEEN TAKING
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WE WILL PLACE
SB FOUR FIFTY TWO PINE SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION MOVING ON SB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX ON ALTERNATIVE
FUEL AND VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
BY SENATOR GONZALEZ. WHO IS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE AND THERE IS
NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE. MOVE ON TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY IN THAT ROOM IS EMPTY AS
WELL MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
QUEUE OF ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX GONZALEZ. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN TWO SIX PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL MOVE ON OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX DURING A
PRIMARY WITNESSES THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. SEVEN
TWO SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. IDO
HAVE ONE COMMENTING Q. IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT Y.
NUMBER. AND OUR COMMENT COMES
FROM ONE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SENATOR JOHN SECURING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOUNG.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
TWENTY SIX SINGLE QUESTIONS FOR
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB SEVEN TWENTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVING ON AS BEFORE
SIXTY FIVE BY SENATOR EGGMAN ON
MENTAL HEALTH. THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES AND SUPPRIMER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WILL OPEN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY RIGHT HERE
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WILL GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BEFORE SIX FIVE. BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR SIX
FIVE. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE WILL GO TO OPPOSITION-
AND THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. ASSEMBLY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE TO
PLACE THIS BEFORE SIXTY FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH O SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. FOUR SIX
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
NO QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOUR SIX FIVE BY
CENTER EGGMAN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. MOVIE ON SB SIX OH
FIVE I CENTER EGGMAN ON MEDICAL
DEVICE RIGHT TO PREPARE. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES. AND
SO WE WILL OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
ON SB SIX SEVEN FIVE. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE THERE'S SO MANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO LINES IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HELLO DANIEL CANDLE CARDS
ARE ON THE HEALTH OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND I
HAVE ABOUT FIVE MORE IN Q. OUR
NEXT COMMENTED FROM LINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS PAUL KELLY I'M
AS CERTIFIED BY MEDICAL
EQUIPMENT TECHNICIAN WITH FORTY
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE IN
HEALTHCARE TECHNOLOGY
MANAGEMENT. AND I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT SB SIX OH FIVE FOR A
PATIENT. THANK YOU READY TO
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS KEVIN O. RILEY THE APP
DO YOU- HELP- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT ACTION ABOUT SIX OH
FIVE I ALSO HAVE A LIST OF
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT STEPS TO
VOICE THEIR SUPPORT THEIR
BEHALF. ON BEHALF OF SUBJECTS
SO TECHNOLOGY HELLO JUST HOSTED
SECURE REPAIR THE REPAIR
ASSOCIATION STRATEGIC
HEALTHCARE TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATE
ASSOCIATION OF MEDICAL DEVICE
SERVICE ORGANIZATION. I MEDICAL
SYSTEMS P. P. RADIOLOGICAL
SERVICES HELLO THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF CLINICAL ENGINEERING
A CO SPONSOR I THINK THAT ALSO
COULD COMPLIANCE- THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY AND
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES OR AFSCME
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIANS AGAINST
WASTE IT'S A TEACHING OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
DISTRICTS. CALIFORNIANS HAVE
YOU ARE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
RETIRED AMERICANS THANK. YOU
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK.
WE HOPE IT WILL BE OKAY WE THE
WORLD US OF THE- WE GOT THANK
YOU MORE ACT. ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
PARTICULARLY YOU A LOT OF GROUP.
THANK RYAN TO SEVENTY FOR GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS NOT A HOME
FROM JOHN MAYER HEALTH AND OF
BILL SIX OH FIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. EVAN KERMIT
CERTIFIED CLINICAL ENGINEER
CERTAINLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS-
THE PROPOSAL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NINE ONE FIFTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS HELENE
FROM AMMAN TO HELP SOLUTION AND
SUPPORT- XL FIVE. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME RIGHT WE WANNA
GO TO OPPOSITION OF SB SIX OH
FIVE THIRD- PRIMARY WITNESSES
SO WE'LL GO TO THIS ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE. SOMEBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB SIX OH FIVE BY
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THE FIRST Y. NUMBER. OUR FIRST
COVERAGES FROM LYING TO EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MISTER
CAREY MEMBERS FEELING GREASY
DANCE MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
GOING TO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS DEAN TALLY ON
THE APP THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS CHRIS CONWELL
PRESENTING THE MEDICAL IMAGING
AND TECHNOLOGY ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION THAT SB SIX UP FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I TWO
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH IN BRIGHTON ON BEHALF OF
THE REPAIR DONE RIGHT COALITION
WE RESPECTFULLY BUT STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE HEARD
FROM THE SPORT IN OPPOSITION OF
SB SIX OH FIVE AND THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB SIX OH
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB FOUR SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR
MAN ON CALIFORNIA FINANCING LAW
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MR MINUTES
AWAY PRESENTATION. SO WE'LL
MOVE RIGHT INTO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY THERE IS NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE. AND
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MARTYRS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR MEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
TWO COMMENTS THANK YOU WILL GO
TO LINE TWO SEVENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT AFTERNOON.
ONE MOMENT. BY TWO SEVEN THREE
SORRY ABOUT THAT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I'VE BEEN IN JERRY
MEMBERS TYPICALLY BEARING WITH
THE PUBLIC LAWCENTER INTO COURT
AT FOUR SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE INTO EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
MAGGIE REMEMBERED WHAT BAD
STATIC LEGAL SERVICES IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT THE FOUR SEVENTY SIX
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO OUT.
YES HELLO AGAIN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIELLE CANTO KAISER
ON BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL THE CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CONSUMER COALITION AND
THE NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW
CLINIC WE URGE YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT
OPPOSITION SB FOUR SEVENTY SIX.
I UNDERSTAND ARE TWO PRIMARY
WITNESSES HAVE DECIDED NOT TO
TESTIFY. SO IN THAT CASE WE
WILL OPEN UP THE GENERAL PUBLIC
COMMENT. OPPOSED IN THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. THERE IS
NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE. IS THERE ROOM FOR
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY IT
SHOULD BE TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED
TO SP FOUR SEVENTY SIX MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO
WISHES TO OPPOSE US BEFORE
SEVEN SIX BY SENATOR MAN. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AS B. FOUR SEVEN
SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE SEVENTY
SIX AND THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SP FOUR SEVEN SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPEND. SENATOR MAN
ALSO HAS SB FIVE HUNDRED ON A
CONDOM IS VEHICLES ZERO
EMISSIONS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE- AND THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
AND WE WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY HERE
SOMEBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WATER IS THERE ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE HUNDRED. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIVE HUNDRED PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK
FOR OPPOSITION SB FIVE HUNDRED
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
WITH A ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE.
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION IN OF ANY ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB. FIVE HUNDRED. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE HUNDRED
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HAVE A COMMENT
FROM ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JUST
HIRE WORKERS LOCOMOTION GROUP
WE MUST RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
BILL AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
HAVE A TICKETS CORNER POSITION
SB FIVE HUNDRED. AND SEEN-
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
HUNDRED GO TO SUSPENSE. WILL
MOVE TO SENATOR RAZA RICE TO
BILLS STARTING WITH SB FORTY
ONE ON SENTENCING SPECIAL
CIRCUMSTANCES. THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OPPOSITE
WAY PRESENTATION THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SO OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN SUPPORT FORTY TWO OR
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN SUPPORT
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATE
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHT ONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR EIGHT
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
ABOUT TWENTY N. Q. WILL GO
TRYING TO FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS LENA
VASQUEZ RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES
OR SB FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
BRING TO EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL I'M SORRY DID YOU
SAY TO WAITING FOR YOUR VOICE
CUT UP ORIENTATION PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANNA
MANUKYAN RESIDENTS OF
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
TOOL FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ZERO FOUR HEARING YOUR CASH I
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE FORTY EIGHT
I'M SORRY- MY NAME IS RACHEL
BURTON I'M A MEMBER OF THE
FAMILY UNITED TO END L. WALK
AND ALSO INITIATE JUSTICE AND I
WANT TO STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU TRYING TO- TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS CLAUDIA
GUTIERREZ I LIVE IN THE CITY OF
REGINA CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWO FOUR EIGHT. HI
CAN YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN YES GO
AHEAD. OKAY SORRY I WOULD BEEN
GIVEN THE NUMBER I APOLOGIZE MY
NAME IS MERRY MARIN ON THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUENTS ON
SUPPORT OF SENATE SENATE BILL
FORTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS QUINN
CIRCUMSTANCE- CALIFORNIA I AM
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
ONE I MEAN FOR EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
IRAN COMMITTEE I CANNOT FROM
SUSANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU I WON FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I THANK YOU ON A ROLL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
ADRIAN DAVIS AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER FIVE
THOUSAND JOKES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY INCARCERATED WITH A
LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE SENTENCE I
AM IN FULL SUPPORT AND SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I TO SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS SHANNON
COLEMAN FROM RIDGECREST
CALIFORNIA I'M CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORTER S. B. FOUR
EIGHT ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I TO SIXTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS MINISTER WILL NOT
MOVE MIKE STEPHENSON- HERE SO
THE CALIFORNIA WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THE HELPLESS AND COKE
BOTTLES S. B. FORTY ONE. THANK
YOU THANK YOU I WON NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS LAYLA SHERRY
ON SITTING I RESIDE IN SHERMAN
OAKS CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHT
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN
TO AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS BRENDA SANCHEZ AND I
AM FROM COMPTON CALIFORNIA AND
I AM A STRONG SUPPORTER SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I WON EIGHTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO JERRY MEMBERS THANK YOU
HI MY NAME IS CRISTIANA HERA I
AM AN ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
I REMEMBER AS DEMOCRATIC AND A
LOT AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT OF
JUST BEFORE EATING ONE DRUG.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS THOMAS JACK
LEE AND I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF S. B. FORTY ONE BECAUSE I
BELIEVE EVERYBODY IS POSSIBLE
TO CHANGE. THANK YOU I WON ALL
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS BRENDA HAFNER AND I'M
CALLING. IN SUPPORT OF BEEN
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE ON BEHALF OF ALL THE
L. WALTRIP RESERVE SHOULD BE
RELEASED THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
NEED TO. YOU STILL HAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS EVELYN PICKENS I'M
IN SAN DIEGO CALIFORNIA I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT SB FORTY ONE.
THANK YOU I DON'T WANNA FORTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS ERICA ROACH I AND FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MY NAME IS JESSICA OF THE
VIENNA RESIDENT BAKER SHOW
CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHT ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN TO
FIFTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS KARLEY SALE BROKEN
RIGHT INCOME OKAY CALIFORNIA- I.
THANK YOU. FOR THANK YOU RIGHT
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOANNA VON
FROM BAKERSFIELD CALIFORNIA AND
I'M STRONG SUPPORT SB FOUR
EIGHT ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT TO THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
BLUNT AND I'M ACTUALLY FROM
ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA WITH
FAMILY UNITED AND THEY'LL WALK
AND I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT- SUPPORT SB CORE EIGHTY
ONE AND I SUPPORT SB PORT
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I TO FORTY SIX PLEASE GLAD. YES
MY NAME IS STEVEN GREEN RIVER
DISTRICT TWENTY NINE ALL MY
LIFE WITHOUT THEM- MY BUTTONS
BOB DOLE OF THE POLISH
COMMUNITY BUT GOVERNOR BROWN
AND I'M ASKING YOU INCLUDED YOU
SUPPORT SB. FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ERICA HERNANDEZ AND I AM
SUPPORT OUR STRONG SUPPORT SB.
FORTY ONE FORTY ONE. THANK YOU
I WON SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS JANET BERNARD
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY AS A K.
TWELVE EDUCATOR AND AN ADVOCATE
FOR RESTORATIVE JUSTICE I VERY
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
EVERYBODY COULD CONFINE THEIR
COMMENTS CENTER NAME THE
ORGANIZATION AND THEIR POSITION
THAT WOULD BE GREAT. THANK YOU
RYAN TO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
HAD BECOME BACKGROUND- I'M
CALLING. CALIFORNIA IBM CORP SB.
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU I'M
TO EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
LOVE I'M CALLING FROM
PHILADELPHIA CALIFORNIA- STRONG
SUPPORT OKAY THE FOUR EIGHTY
ONE. THANK YOU AYE TO THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ANIL LEHRER FROM FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND THE NUMBER OF
FAMILIES AND I DID FIND ALL UP
AND THEN THEY SHOULD JUST.
CALLING ON THE PART OF A THREE
POINT ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN ONE TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL TRANSPLANT I'M
CALLING FROM FRESNO AND MY
FAMILIES UNITE AND ALOT AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB
FOUR EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU I
WON SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS DIANE CALLING
FROM LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHTY
ONE AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE FAMILY UNITED. IN ARE LIFE
WITHOUT PAROLE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M TO SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
IS MARIA BOB AND I FULLY
SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY TO
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF
THE VALUE GARCIA ON PHONE CALL
A. COUNTY AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE
THANK YOU. DURING TWO THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIVE MILLION
ON THE MODEM OFF ON IT
CALIFORNIANS MUCH FUN OR FORTY
ONE WITH THAT. I BELIEVE
EVERYBODY ABOARD AND- THANK YOU
I WANT FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS TINA GREEN
CO FOUNDER YOU'LL FAMILIES
UNITED TO AND LIFE WITHOUT
PAROLE FROM DISTRICT TWENTY
NINE I STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RYAN TO FIFTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHICH WOULD YOU MIND
ELABORATING WITH FAMILIES
UNITED AND I'LL WALK DROPPED A
LOT AND ISSUE A DOCTOR AND I AM
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN TO- TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY
TWO ZERO TWO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS AMY
AND BEING OUTSIDE LIVE IN THE
CITY OF RECEIVE A CALIFORNIA
AND I'M IN ORDER- SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I TWO SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS STACY HANG
AND I'M CALLING FROM LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA TOLLEY AT THE PORT
SB FOUR EIGHTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE THREE OH TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
PETER HERNANDEZ WITH FAMILIES
UNITED FOR AND I'LL WALK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU I'M
THRILLED FOR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES I LEAN CALLING FROM ORANGE
COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA
WITH. BAMILEKE UNITED AND I'LL
WALK AND SHE- LONG SUPPORT OF
S. B. FORTY ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AYE CHIU FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WONDERLAND AND
HOW STRONGLY SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY
NINE KM. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
ALSO PLEASE GO. BUDGETARY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS
MORNING AS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB FORTY ONE AND A
PART BECAUSE SPONSORED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE OH
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TO SECURELY MITCHELL
KENTUCKY BANK IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M THREE
OH NINE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS NAOMI SANCHEZ-
FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I'M IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF FOUR EIGHTY
ONE. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVEN'T
TAKEN THE SUPPORT FOR FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. WHEN I MOVED
OPPOSITION IN THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
VOTERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED AS BEFORE EIGHT
ONE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FOUR
EIGHT ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENTING
Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT MY NUMBER. AT OUR COMIC
COMES FROM LYING TO FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WAS A LITTLE
BIT HIGHER. QUITE THE COR
EIGHTY ONE. A GUY WITH BLACK
AND JEWISH AND EXTRA RECORD
FREQUENTLY REJECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT Q. ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN SUPPORT IN OPPOSITE OF US
FORTY ONE INCHING QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION IS BEFORE ANYONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON TO SB
SIX SEVEN FOUR BY SENATOR TO
RAZA ON PUBLIC CONTRACTS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE OFFICE
WAY PRESENTATION BUT WE DO HAVE
ONE PRIMARY WITNESS IN SUPPORT
ON THE COASTLINE MISS ABOLITION
BOLEH A SENIOR POLICY
COORDINATOR FOR JOBS TO MOVE
AMERICA. MS BOLEH ARE YOU HERE.
YES I'M HERE ALL RIGHT PLEASE
TELL US ABOUT SB. SIX SEVEN
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ABHISHEK
BHALLA AND I'M A SENIOR POLICY
COORDINATOR JOBS TO MOVE
AMERICA A NATIONAL STRATEGIC
RESEARCH AND POLICY CENTER
DEDICATED TO ENSURING THAT
PUBLIC DOLLARS ARE SPENT IN A
WAY THAT MAXIMIZES THE PUBLIC
GOOD. I'M HERE TODAY TO VOICE
STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX SEVEN FOR
THE CALIFORNIA JOBS PLAN. THE
CALIFORNIA JOB THEN THE SIMPLE
POLICY TOOL WHICH ALLOWS
ECONOMIC EFFECT OF OUR PUBLIC
POLICY MAXIMIZE. THERE ARE NO
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS ALL THE
CALIFORNIA JOCKS IN ACQUIRED
THAT COMPANIES. APPLYING FOR
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION CONTRACT.
FELL OUT THE FORM AND THEN
COMPLY WITH THEIR OWN
COMMITMENTS ONCE THE CONTRACT
IS AWARDED. ON THE SMALL CHANGE
ALLOWED TECH TO SHIP THE
FRAMEWORK WITH THEM THAT WILL
COME. CAME FROM LABOR COSTS.
AND JOB QUAN EACH WITH THE THAT
REWARDS COMPANIES BAKER LIVING
WAGE. THE COMMUNITY TO ME BUT
NOT. THE CALIFORNIA JOBS IS A
COMMON OF A LEARNING EMPOWER
CALLED THE U. S. EMPLOYMENT
PLAN WHICH IS FIRST PILOT IN
TWENTY ELEVEN THE LOS ANGELES
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY. AND HASN'T BEEN USED
ACROSS THE COUNTRY TO CREATE
THOUSANDS OF JOBS THAT LOCAL
COMMUNITY. AND AFTER ANALYZING
TEN YEARS WORTH OF DATA ON
PROCUREMENT. A SENIOR PROFESSOR
AT UCLA LAW SCHOOL CONCLUDED
THAT THE INCLUDING OF THE U. S.
B. P. ON MAJOR RAIL CAR
PROCUREMENT HAD NO NOTICEABLE
IMPACT. ON EITHER THE PRICE OR
THE. NUMBER OF BIDDERS ON EACH
CONTRACT. CAN WE JUST BENEFITS
AND QUALITY OF AND HOW. AND
CREATE ACTIVE JOB FOR CAN YOU.
WHO BASICALLY I CAN BEAR TO. A
PEOPLE COLOR IN WOMEN WILL
STIMULATE ECONOMY BY. AND LOCAL
CA LEVEL SPENDING AND REDUCE
RELIANCE ON THE SOCIAL. NET
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IN FOR
COMMUTER HOW. INTO THE- AT
AFFECTED BY THE COLD AT
NINETEEN CAMPAñA. ALSO MAKE UP
A DISK. SHARE OF WORKERS MAKING
MINIMUM WAGE. BY PRIORITIZING
BETTER TO CREATE PATHWAYS TO
JOBS FOR INDIVIDUALS. OR GROUPS
COLLUDED COMMUNE FUND PLANET
THIS BILL CAN HELP INVEST IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE CARRIED.
BIGGEST BURDEN DURING THE
PANDEMIC. THE BILL WILL COST
TAXPAYERS LESS THAN. TO OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED ONE POINT
FIVE DOLLAR INVESTMENT IN
VEHICLE. WHILE SPENDING ON
GREEN INVESTMENT CREATE MORE
JOBS PER DOLLAR THAN ANY OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT. AND
EVERY ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
SPENDING ON RENEWABLE ENERGY
CREATE SEVEN POINT FIVE FULL
TIME JOBS. ACCOUNTANT JOBS PLAN
WILL ALLOW US TO MAXIMIZE THE
ECONOMIC. THAT OUR PUBLIC
INVESTMENT AND CREATE GOOD HIGH
QUALITY JOB FOR COMMUNITIES IN
NEED IN THE MAIL. TODAY I THINK
WITH OVER TWENTY COMMUNITY
LABOR EMPLOYMENT INDUSTRY
ORGANIZATION. ZERO REGISTER
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. ABOUT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU HAVING HEARD FROM THE
PRIMARY WITNESS WILL NOW OPEN
THE GENERAL PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE IF YOU HAVE
ANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB
SIX SEVEN FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH SPEAK IN SEPT OF AN B.
C. SEVEN FOUR PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ONE
COMMENT ONE SIX NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS MIKE MOLLY
GONNA BE AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL AND THE WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL WORKERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. RIGHT WILL
NOW MOVE ON OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX SEVENTY FOUR THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES. THERE'S
NOBODY HERE IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE THERE'S NOBODY AROUND
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR. IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX SEVEN
FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX
SEVEN FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SIX SEVEN
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPEND
SPECIFICALLY MOVING ON THE
SENATE OF THE MON HAS THREE
BILLS BEFORE US. THE FIRST ONE
IS SB FOUR NINETY SEVEN ON
QUALIFYING ACCOUNTS FOR DIRECT
DEPOSIT A PUBLICLY ADMINISTERED
FUNDS. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAVE
PRESENTATION AND THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES AND WILL OPEN
UP THE PUBLIC HEARING IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE WITH SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY HERE SOMEBODY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WATER IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FOUR
NINE SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
ONE COMMENT FROM ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO OUT. HELLO
DANIEL KENDALL KAISER ON BEHALF
OF THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE
NATIONAL CONSUMER LAW CLINIC IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE
COMPOSITION OF THIS BEFORE
NINETY SEVEN. THERE'S NOBODY
HERE ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN OPPOSITION SB
FOUR NINE SEVEN. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. FOUR NINE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT HAVE BEEN TAKING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORTIN
OPPOSITION OF US BEFORE NINETY
SEVEN BY CENTER LEMOND. AND
SEEN OF QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
THIS BEFORE NINE SEVEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE BY CENTER THE MOMS
FUND BIO MAKER BIOMARKER
TESTING. THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES. WILL OPEN A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. AND THERE
IS NOBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE
HERE. ASSEMBLY ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BATTERIES OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF
SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE THREE FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN THE SUPPORT WORKER
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY HERE ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE OPPOSED SB FIVE THIRTY
FIVE THERE'S NOBODY ROOMS
TWENTY FORTY. BATTERY PLEASE
COULD OF ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE THREE
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
THREE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN THE
SPORT IN OPPOSITION ON SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE AND THERE'S NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE
THIRTY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING ON SB SEVEN OF TWO. BY
SENATOR RAMON I'M GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENTS OF REPORT. THIS IS
A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THERE
ARE NO THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND WE
WILL OPEN THE PUBLIC COMMENT
HERE FORTY TWO OR THREE AND
THERE'S NOBODY HERE. SOME OF
THE TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MATTER IF YOU COULD QUEUE
UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE.
THAT IS IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
OH TWO BY SENATOR LAMONT. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN OH TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
COMMENT GQ IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THEIR Y. NUMBER. BY
TWO FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS NOT A MANDATE ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY AND
SUPPORTED SB SEVEN OH TWO.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
TURN TO OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
OH TO- THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NO MINIMUM TWENTY FORTY. NINER
PLEASE CALL UP ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB SEVEN OH
TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
SEVEN OH TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTING
KILL. ALL RIGHT WE TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN OH TWO AND THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN OH
TWO LIMóN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
SENATOR RUBIO IS THREE BILLS
BEFORE US BEGINNING WITH SB
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN ON CHILD
WELFARE DOMESTIC. VIOLENCE THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE CENTER
REVIEWS WAY PRESENTATION AND
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL
START HERE ROOM FORTY CHOI
THREE WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS AND
THERE IS NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WILL MOVE ON TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. THERE'S
NOBODY THERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINE MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB FIVE THREE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION SB
FIVE THREE SEVEN THERE'S NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
SO GO TO ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY HERE VETERANS
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE MODERATE PLEASE QUEUE UP
ANYONE OPPOSED TO SB. FIVE
THREE SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB FIVE THREE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. ALL RIGHT WE'VE
TAKEN SUPPORT OPPOSITION AND SB
FIVE THREE SEVEN IN THERE NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE THREE
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO SB FIVE THREE EIGHT
BY SENATOR RUBIO DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE THE SENATORS
WAY PRESENTATION THERE NO
PRIMARY WITNESSES SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION AND WILL OPEN A
PUBLIC COMMENT HEARING FORTY
TWO OR THREE AND THERE'S NOBODY
HERE. MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY AND THERE'S NOBODY THERE
MODERATOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE
THREE EIGHT BY SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE THREE
EIGHT. PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THEY
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENT
THANK YOU FOR GOING TO FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HIGHLINE
THERE MARIN ANNOUNCED ACTUALLY
IN SUPPORT OF FIVE. THREE
SEVEN- I DON'T KNOW WHAT
HAPPENED BUT I WAS LATE
NINETEEN SO. THAT'S NOT THE
POINT OF IT THE. FIVE THREE
SEVEN THANK YOU WE GOTCHA THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ELIZABETH
HENRY AGAIN FROM LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA SAVE LAFAYETTE
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF. FIVE THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME WE WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION TO THE SP
FIVE THIRTY BY SENATOR RUBIO
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FIVE SHOULD BE FORTY TWO OH
THREE SO MANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATE OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE THREE
EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
THREE EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT HAVE A TAKE IN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE THREE EIGHT AND SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FOR MY COLLEAGUES
THAT OBJECTION SB FIVE THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
SB EIGHT OH FIVE BY SENATOR
RUBIO AND SMALL NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS ORGANIZATIONS.
THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
SUSPENSE THE OFFICE WAY
PRESENTATION THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO OPEN A PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE. THERE'S
NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH THREE TO
SUPPORT. SB EIGHT OH FIVE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY TWENTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB EIGHT OH
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT
ZERO FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TEN
COMMENTS IN Q. OR TIMELINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ELIZABETH HENRY LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
EIGHT ZERO FIVE. THANK YOU I'M
THREE TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
PROPOSED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS ADVOCATE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY THREE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BECKY
DAVIS AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
AND SUPPORT AND SB EIGHT OH
FIVE ALTERING THE PLAYHOUSE IN
ALAMEDA CALIFORNIA SOUTH VALLEY
CIVIC THEATRE IN MORGAN HILL
CALIFORNIA LIMELIGHT ACTORS
THEATRE IN GILROY. EAST BAY
CHILDREN'S THEATRE IN OAKLAND
SOUTH BAY MUSICAL THEATER IN
SARATOGA STARLIGHT THEATRE IN
MARTINEZ AND THE PUPPETRY INCH
INSTITUTE IN CAPITOLA. THANK
YOU VERY TO SEVENTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR MY NAME IS MARTHA DENSON
I'M THE BOARD PRESIDENT OF THE
THEATRICAL PRODUCERS LEAGUE OF
LOS ANGELES THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR SMALL THEATERS
IN LA COUNTY THE LEAGUE
STRONGLY URGES YOU TO SUPPORT
SB EIGHT OH FIVE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE IT'S ESSENTIAL TO
ENSURE PAY EQUITY INPUT ARTIST
BACK TO WORK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY TO SEVENTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. PARKER I'M
REPRESENTING THE ALLIANCE OF
GAZETTEERS AND COACHELLA VALLEY
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT ACTUALLY
IN YOUR CAR. THANK YOU READY TO
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS BEATRICE KATHY GRANT I
AM THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
THEATRICAL PRODUCERS LEAGUE OF
LOS ANGELES AND THE ARTISTIC
DIRECTOR OF THE BILLIONS JUMPED
PERCEPTION IMPORT OF SB EIGHT
OH FIVE. THANK YOU TO NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
MY NAME IS GRETCHEN RESULTS ARE
AND I AND THE BOARD PRESIDENT
OF HEALTHIER COMPANY IN
LAFAYETTE IN AND WE ARE TRYING
TO PUT IT AT SPEED OF FIVE.
THANK YOU I TWO EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME THE%
MENU ABILITY AS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CASA THERE WONDER
ONE THEATER IN BOYLE HEIGHTS
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
EIGHT OH FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS BILLY
MADISON ON THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF CAPTIVITY ON IN SAN
JOSE AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AT THE EIGHT OH FIVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RYAN THREE
TEAM PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JEANINE WAS OFF THE
SCALE AND THEN THE MANAGING
DIRECTOR OF THE NEW AMERICAN
THEATRE IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ANIMAL THEATER ARTISTS AND I
SUPPORT SB EIGHT OH FIVE AND I
HOPE YOU DO TOO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT HAVING TAKEN
THE SUPPORT THAT'S MOVED
OPPOSITION SB EIGHT OH FIVE.
SINGLE IN A ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. SO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT OH
FIVE BY SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. EIGHT ZERO
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ONE
MIGHT IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THAT MY NUMBER.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
OTHER COMMENT COMES FROM LINE.
THREE TWENTY FOUR. NINE THREE
TWO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BERMAN TOLD SUPPORT- I'M FROM
LEGACY PROGRAMS EDUCATION
REENTRY. WHAT. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
WE'VE TAKEN THE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION S. B. EIGHT OH FIVE
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES TO THAT OBJECTION IF
IT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB FIVE FORTY SIX BY SENATOR
WILL CONTINUE TO CATIONS
LIFELINE UNIVERSE UNIVERSAL
SERVICE THIS IS AN URGENCY
MATTER AND THIS BILL IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
THERE'S NO PRIMARY WITNESSES.
AND WE'LL GO RIGHT TO ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE FOR COMMENTS
THERE'S NOBODY HERE- PUBLIC
COMMENT IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
THERE'S NOBODY THERE MODERATORS
OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FORTY SIX BY
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. FIVE FOUR SIX PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENTS IN
Q. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF THE SB FIVE FOUR
SIX THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE OPPOSERS NOBODY ON
THE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR FIFTY Q. OF ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. FIVE
FOUR SIX. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FIVE FOUR SIX PLEASEPRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
FORTY SIX THERE'S NO QUESTIONS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT BILL SHOULD GO
THE SUSPENSE MOVING ON SB FIVE
FIFTY TWO SENATOR HERTZBERG
DROPPED PLANNING SMALL WATER
SUPPLIERS THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE SENATORS WAY
PRESENTATION THERE'S NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THERE'S
NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN HIS NEW
NO ONE ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO TESTIFY MODERATES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FIVE FIVE TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE TWO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ONE
COMMENT GQ RIGHT EIGHTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH
HENRY ST LAFAYETTE LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF
SENATOR HERTZBERG'S FIVE FIVE
TWO. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT. I'M IN A ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATE OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB.
FIVE FIVE TWO. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
ASK THE FIVE FIVE TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
WE'VE IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION IN
THERE NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES IN SB FIVE FIVE TWO
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SB FIVE FIVE
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVIE
HONESTLY SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG ON DENSITY
BONUS LAW- THIS IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. FOR AND
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. A
PRIMARY WITNESSES WILL OPEN UP
THE PUBLIC HEARING IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S
NOBODY HERE WILL GO TO FORTY
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NOBODY
THERE. WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE IS ANYONE IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN TO EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AB
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT
AFTERNOON MR CARE NUMBERS
DOESN'T MATTER NOT LIKE HOW
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF OF HABITAT HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA. BONKERS THAT
MEASURE IN RECORD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EVER FROM EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ELIZABETH LAW
CALIFORNIA INTO OF. TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU I NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU IT THIS TIME
WHAT OPPOSITION OF S. B. SEVEN
TWO EIGHT BY SENATOR THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM THERE'S
NOBODY ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATES O ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB. SEVEN
TWENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB SEVEN TO EIGHT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT RIDICULOUS
FOR IN OPPOSITION AND THERE'S
NO QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
THAT OBJECTION SB SEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE COMING UP TO SB
FIVE FIVE NINE BY SENATOR HER
TADO WHO. I THINK WAS GOING TO
PRESENT. THE ANNOUNCER ALL
RIGHTS. TO CAN I MOVE ON THE
SENATOR NEWMAN QUITE NASTY.
MARK YOU GUYS UP THERE SHE IS
OKAY SENATOR TITLE PLEASE COME
UP. QUITE A GIVEN THE TIME IF
YOU COULD BE BRIEF THAT WOULD
BE VERY MUCH APPRECIATED. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND-
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT SB FIVE
FIVE NINE. FOUR FIVE GOOD
AFTERNOON MR TURN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME TO PRESENT BUT
I WANT TO REALLY STRESS THE
URGENCY OF SB FIVE FIVE NINE-
YOU SEE WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF
A GLOBAL FOOD CRISIS THAT
REQUIRES IMMEDIATE ACTION TO
PREVENT. POTENTIALLY FAMINE
HAPPENING HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND BEYOND- ONE THAT COULD FIND
YOUR CONSTITUENTS AND MIND
SEARCHING FOR FOOD. THEY CAN
ACTUALLY AFFORD AS PRICES GO UP
IN RESPONSE TO DECREASED WATER
ACCESS AND INCREASED COST IN
GETTING FOOD. WHERE IT'S GOING
FROM FARMS TO GROCERY STORES
AND EVENTUALLY OUR DINNER
TABLES. MY BILL SB FIVE FIVE
NINE THE STATE WATER RESILIENCY
ACT CAN HELP US PREVENT FAMINE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. LAST
SESSION I INTRODUCED A BILL OF
THE SAME NUMBER THE REQUESTED
FUNDING TO RESTORE. THE
CARRYING CAPACITY OF THE
FRANKLIN CANAL. THAT BILL WAS
ULTIMATELY VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR BUT STARTED A LARGER
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW AND
WHERE WE SHOULD BE SPENDING
MONEY WHEN WE HAVE IT TO REPAIR
MUCH NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT CAN BETTER PREPARE US FOR
OUR WATER NEEDS IN DROUGHT AND
NON DROUGHT YEARS. IN RECENT
DECADES THE LEGISLATURE HAS
MADE WISE DECISIONS AND INVEST.
TO INVEST IN REPAIRING OUR
CRUMBLING INFRASTRUCTURE.
INCLUDING THE NINETEEN NINETY
SEVEN THE PROCREATION OF OVER
ONE BILLION FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A NEW. AT BAY
BRIDGE BETWEEN SAN FRANCISCO
AND OAKLAND- THOUGH THE BRIDGE
WAS DELAYED IN OPENING AND COST
SIGNIFICANTLY. MORE THAN
ORIGINALLY ESTIMATE THE STATE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THE PROJECT
BECAUSE OF THE MOST. BECAUSE
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST HEAVILY
TRAVELED BRIDGES IN OUR STATE
AND IT WAS NECESSARY TO REPAIR.
AN INVESTMENT IN OUR FAMILY
WATER DELIVERY SYSTEM IS NO
LESS IMPORTANT TO OUR STATE AND
ALL OF US. THAT LIVE HERE WE
GROW CROPS THAT FEED US AND THE
WORLD. BUT THIS IS NOT JUST
ABOUT SECURING OUR FOOD SUPPLY
CHAIN THIS IS WATER USE BY
RESIDENTS IN RURAL COMMUNITIES
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND BY
URBAN USERS. AND LOS ANGELES
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY ONE
MILLION. SOME OF WHO LIVE IN
OUR STATE'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. IT IS ESTIMATED
THAT ABOUT 60% OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY RECEIVES WATER THROUGH
THE THROUGH THE COMPLAINTS
PROJECTS IN THIS BILL. THIS
WATER ALSO PROTECTS THE LARGEST
REMAINING WETLAND COMPLEX IN
THE WESTERN UNITED STATES WHICH
IS HOME TO OVER ONE MILLION
MIGRATING BIRDS AND IS
RECOGNIZED AS THE WETLAND OF
INTERNATIONAL IMPORTANCE.
HOWEVER WITH THAT BEING SAID
LET'S NOT DISCOUNT THE IMPACT
THIS LEGISLATION WILL HAVE ON
OUR AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY
EITHER. ACCORDING TO THE UNITED
NATIONS JUST FIFTEEN CROPS.
PROVIDE 90% OF THE WORLD'S FOOD
ENERGY AND TAKE. WITH THREE
WHEAT MAIZE AND RICE MAKING UP
TWO THIRDS OF THIS CALIFORNIA
IS NUMBER TWO IN RICE
PRODUCTION IN THE UNITED STATES
PROVIDING FOOD SECURITY. THE
DROUGHT HOWEVER HAS CAUSED AT
LEAST WHAT WE KNOW A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES OF RICE TO BE
PUT OUT OF PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA ALONE. THAT'S
MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF RICE THAT
ARE LOST. BERMAN CONTRIBUTES
ABOUT FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS TO
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY EVERY YEAR
AND THAT'S WITHOUT COUNTING FOR
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT ON FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES ALL OVER THE
STATE. IN CALIFORNIA WE
RECOGNIZE OUR STRATEGIC
ADVANTAGES IN CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES AND HAVE ACTED TO
ENSURE THEY HAVE STAYED STRONG.
AND IN TWENTY FOURTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALLOCATED ONE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS. TO
FILM AND TELEVISION PRODUCTIONS
RICHARD THOSE PRODUCTION STAY
HERE THAT'S THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND I SUPPORTED WE NEED THOSE
JOBS IN OUR STATE. BUT JUST
LIKE OTHER PARTS OF CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA'S AGRICULTURE
INDUSTRY IS A WORLD LEADER
THREE OF THE FOUR LARGEST
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCING COUNTIES
IN THE UNITED STATES. ARE IN MY
SENATE DISTRICT WE NEED THE
JOBS THIS INDUSTRY SUPPORTS TO
PERHAPS MORE IMPORTANTLY
CALIFORNIA NEEDS THE FOOD THAT
THIS INDUSTRY PRODUCES. IN THE
NATION NEEDS THIS FOOD SB FIVE
FIVE NINE PROVIDES US THE
OPPORTUNITY AN OPPORTUNITY NOT
ONLY TO PLAN FOR FUTURE BUT TO
PROTECT IT AS WELL. THE BILL
REQUEST SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
CANAL CONVEYANCE REPAIRS OVER
THE COURSE OF TEN YEARS.
REPAIRS WILL PROVIDE A NET
BENEFIT TO THE ENTIRE STATE.
BOB AND FOR ALL THESE REASONS
I- HAVE HERE WITH ME JENNIFER
PIERRE GENERAL MANAGER WITH THE
STATE WATER CONTRACTORS AND
ALEX BURNED BRIGHT WATER THIRTY.
ALL RIGHT I'M HI THIS IS ALEX
DURING TRIAL WATER FROM FIRE
WATER THIRTY- GOOD AFTERNOON
THAT CHAIR PORTANTINO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WILL MAKE
JUST A VERY FEW COMMENTS CARE-
AS SENATOR HER TADO MENTIONED
THERE. THE SECOND TIME THIS
BILL HAS BEEN SEEN IN SOME FORM
BY THE COMMITTEE SINCE THAT
TIME NEED TO PROGRESS IN
BROADENING OUR COALITION TO
OTHER WATER AUTHORITIES IN
DEVELOPING A FUNDING PACKAGE.
RIGHT WATER THIRTY HAS
ASSEMBLED TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND FEDERAL
FUNDS AND A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION AT A MINIMUM IN
THE LOCAL COST SHARE FOR
REPAIRING FRANKLIN CANAL WORST
CITED SECTION. THIS SHOWS THAT
THE TROOP KASH THE TRUE COST
SHARING PARTNERSHIPS ARE
POSSIBLE FOR THE SUCH THESE ARE
THE PRIME. AND HOPEFULLY SHE
COULD NOT OF THE FAITH THAT
INVEST WILL BE MADE OKAY. THANK
YOU I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY AND
JENNY WHO. THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS AND CAN SPEAK TO
THE- ISSUES WITH THE CALIFORNIA.
AND- THE PLANS THERE. ALL RIGHT
TO REIMBURSABLE. WELL THAT WAS
ME HELLO RUN. OUT WITHOUT
DURING I WAS OUT I'M SURE YOU
RIVER ME AND I MESSED UP NAME.
BY SORRY ABOUT THAT AND SO
JENNIFER NOT TEST. WRECKED
WHERE SHE IS NOW ALL THE
STRUGGLING TO THE BILLABLE THEY
INTERACTION I'M GONNA GOT A IT
OKAY. WITH THAT WILL GO TO
OTHER MEMBERS FOR THE COMMENT
THIS NUN HERE IT IS HERE IN
INTO FORTY. C. ANYWAY THERE NO
THAT'S GOING TO PHONE LINE
ANYONE ELSE SINCE OF. ON THE
PHONE LINE MY- OF SB FIVE FIVE.
H. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
INTO OF A FIVE FIVE NINE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AND
THIS TIME. I HAVE ONE COMMON
THREE Q. RITE AID. PLEASE CALL.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
YOU'RE A MAY HAVE FOR THE BOARD
TO SEE AND FRESH UNTIL KING. IN
STRONG THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION NOW THERE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION THERE'S
NOBODY REPORTED TWO OR THREE IN
OPPOSITION. THERE'S NOBODY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION-
MINERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB. FIVE FIVE
NINE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
FIVE NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ASK I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT THINGS WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FIVE
NINE. NO QUESTIONS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES. CLOSE PLEASE. UP
FOR ALL THESE REASONS FOR THE
SAKE OF FOOD SECURITY IN OUR
STATE AND OUR NATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ALL RIGHT TO WE EVER ASK
FOR WE'VE GOTTEN A CLOSE THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WITHOUT
OBJECTION THIS BILL SHALL GO TO
SUSPENSE THANK YOU MR WHITE
HOUSE HE'S GONNA TAKE OVER FROM
HERE. BACK EXCEPT WILL BE MOVED
TO SENATOR NEWMAN'S BILLS SB
FIVE FIVE B. THREE VOTER
REGISTRATION- THIS ITEM IS A
SUSPENSE CANDID RECEIVING THIS
WAYS WE PRESENTATION SO LET'S
PROVE THEM RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY CRISTINA WITNESSES
HERE AND FOR- ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. FIVE EIGHT THREE WE HAVE
NO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY THE TESTIFIED MODERATOR
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO TESTIFY
IN TELECONFERENCE LINE SUPPORT.
SB FIVE EIGHT THREE. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE EIGHT THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. ALRIGHT LET'S
MOVE. A FULL SAME PROCESS FOR A
HEARING OPPOSITION I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO OF
THREE IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE
EIGHT THREE- NO WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION
SB FIVE A THREE MODERATE PUT
MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB FIVE A THREE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE EIGHT
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
I WAS BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
SEEING NO HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FIVE A THREE LOSE
DISPENSED COUNTER. NEXT WE HAVE
SB FIVE EIGHT NINE BY CENTER
HUESO ON AIR POLLUTION
ALTERNATIVE VEHICLES AND
VEHICLE TO INFRASTRUCTURE- THIS
ITEM IS THIS ITEM IS ALSO
SPENDS KANDID NY IS WAY
PRESENTATION. SO LET'S MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES HE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE TESTS
FIND SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE
EIGHT NINE. NOR DO I SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. FIVE EIGHT
NINE MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
WITNESSES. WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN A TELECONFERENCE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHT NINE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE EIGHT NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
LET'S HAVING NO- SUPPORT
WITNESSES LET'S MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE IN
OPPOSITION OF FIVE SP FIVE
EIGHT NINE. NOR DO I SEE
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN OPPOSITION FIVE EIGHT NINE
MINOR MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROP WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPSITION OF SB
FIVE EIGHT NINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIVE EIGHT NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT
SINGKIL VERY WELL AS SPRING
PRACTICE MANY SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
P. FIVE EIGHT NINE. THIS IS
DISPENSED CALENDAR MISTER HUESO
ALSO HAS AS BEFORE SEVERAL FIVE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BY
NATIONAL EDUCATION AND
WORKFORCE. OPPORTUNITIES AXES
IT IS AN ITEM ON. ALSO
ASSISTANCE CANDID IN HIS WE
PRESENT WHAT'S MOVED THE TEST.
THERE ARE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN OH FIVE
NOR DO I SEE WITNESSES IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY TWO TESTIFYING
SUPPORTER SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
OH FIVE MODERATOR PLEASE PROMPT
ANYWAY THIS IS WAITING TO
TESTIFY AND THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN OH
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
ALL FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT SINK
YOU VERY WELL AS FULL THE SAME
PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION EITHER
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. IN A POSITION OF S.
B. SEVEN OH FIVE I SEEINGNONE
I SEE NO WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION OF.
SB SEVEN OH FIVE MODERATOR IF
YOU PLEASE WITH PROP ANY
WITNESSES WITING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN OH FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN ZERO
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU VERY
WELL LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBER SEEING NO
HANDS OR QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN OH FIVE IS.
MOVED TO DISPENSE CALENDAR
CENTER GLAZER HAS SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR A COMMUNICABLE DISEASES
RESPIRATORY DISEASE INFORMATION
THIS ITEMS ALSO SUSPENSE CANDID
MISTER GLAZERS WAVE
PRESENTATION- LET'S START. SEE
IF ANYBODY'S WISHING TO TESTIFY
I SEE NO WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE TESTS FIND
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR
NOR DO I SEE ANYONE SYSTEM
ROOM. TWENTY FOURTEEN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SEVEN
FOUR FOUR MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT WITNESSES- WAITING
TESTIFYING TELECONFERENCE LINE
SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN FOUR FOUR
FIVE SENATOR GLAZERS. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE ONE COMMENT
JIM Q. FROM ONE THREE THREE
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. I YES I
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT- SB. FOUR
EIGHTY ONE. OKAY THAT'S NOT THE
ONE THAT WERE ONLINE TO. GO
AHEAD YOUR AVOCADOS FOR MY
EIGHTY ONE. ELIZABETH HENRY
LAFAYETTE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF SEVEN FORTY FOUR. SIX REPORT
HERE I THANK YOU ARE YOU KNOW
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY
GOOD LET'S FULL THE SAME PRICE
IN HERE FOR MANY. I SEE NO
WITNESSES IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN
FOUR FOUR NO JOB I SEE
WITNESSES IN THIS IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY AND SOME
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVEN FOUR
FOUR MODERATOR IF YOU'LL PLEASE
PROMPT THE WITNESSES WILLING TO
TESTIFY IN A POSITION OF SB
SEVEN FOUR FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO SB SEVEN FOUR FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME VERY WELL
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE SEEING NO HAN
SEPARATE QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SEVEN FOUR FOURS
MOVED SPEND SPIRAL. CENTER
GLAZER ALSO HAS S. B. EIGHT OH
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS IS FORESEE TRAINING
CENTRE FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS REPORTING- THIS
ITEM IS ASSIST. ALSO A
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE IN HIS
WAY PRESENTATION. HUSTLE WAS
MOVED TO THE PUBLIC HEARING I
SEE NO WITNESSES A ROOM- FORTY
TWO OR THREE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT OF WAR NOR
DO I SEE ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY TWO TESTS FIND
SUPPORT MODERATOR IF YOU PLEASE
PROP WITNESSES WAITING TESTIFY
ON THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF. SENATOR GLAZERS S.
B. EIGHT OH FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT ZERO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I CURRENTLY HAVE TWO COMMENTING
Q. OR TO LINE THREE THREE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF LINE- S.
B. FOR ANYONE. COURTRIGHT
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
ELIZABETH AND RAIN LAFAYETTE
CALIFORNIA- IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
ZERO FOUR MISTER GLAZERS BILL.
THANK YOU RYAN THREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ROSA RODRIGUEZ I AM SUPPORTING
SB. FOUR EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT G. Q.
RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM THE
SUPPORTERS THIS FALL THE SAME
PROCESS FOR OPPOSITION IS THERE
ANYONE SIX I SEE NO WITNESSES
HERE AND- IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN OPPOSITION THAT SB
EIGHT OH FOUR. NOR DO I SEE
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN OPPOSITION AIRPORT MODERATOR
IF YOU PLEASE PROP WITNESSES
WILLING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. ALE FOR AND
CALL THEM. THANK YOU sYOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. EIGHT ZERO FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME VERY WELL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SEEN NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB EIGHT OH
FOUR. HAS MOVED DISPENSED
COUNTER WE'RE ON OUR LAST BILL
IT'S S. B. SEVEN FIVE FIVE BY
CENTER ROTH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING RELATED
JOB PLACEMENT REPORTING- THIS
ITEM IS ALSO SUSPENDS CANDID
AND MISTER ROB THIS WAY
PRESENTATIONS WILL MOVE TO THE
PUBLIC. TESTIMONY I SEE NO
WITNESSES A ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
FIVE FIVE NOR DO I SEE
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN SUPPORT OF TESTS. TO SUPPORT
SB SEVEN FIVE FIVE MODERATE IF
YOU PLEASE PROP WITNESSES GOING
TO TESTIFY AND TELECONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT OF. A CENTER ROTS SB
SEVEN FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK AND- OF S.
SEVEN FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANKS THAT'S ONE. I GET
SOMETHING TO EAT I KERN HAVE NO
THANK YOU. I WILL GO SHOPPERS
OF SB SEVEN FIVE AYE SENATOR
ROSS NOBODY REPORTED- THREE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOMS- TWENTY
FORTY THEIR MODERATE PLEASE
KEEP UP THE OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN FIVE
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ONE COMMENTING HERE IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT Y.
NUMBER. NINE THREE THREE FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THINK I
MISSED THAT THE NINE AND TEN OR
HEAVY. LONG TIME AGO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL KEEP GOING GET
ON AT. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION OF SB
SEVEN FIVE FIVE WE'VE GOT NO
COMMENTS FROM COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVEN FIVE
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE
HAVE NO BILLS ON CALL. CORRECT
SO THAT CONCLUDES. OUR
BUSINESS- THANK YOU ALL FOR
EVERYBODY PARTICIPATE IN THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY LIKE THAT
WOMAN WHO MISTER DOCTOR
OPPORTUNITY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING THE PROCREATION
COMMITTEE O VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU MOVE PRETTY APPRECIATE YOUR
PRODUCT PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
THAT CONCLUDES OUR AGENDA THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS IS
A GERMAN. THANK YOU.